THREE BILLS ON OUR AGENDA TODAY
WHEN I ASKED THE AUTHORS TO.
COME INTO THE HEARING ROOM
BECAUSE WE'RE GONNA WE'RE GONNA
GET GOING HERE WE HAVE ALMOST
QUORUM BUT WILL BEGIN NOW
ANYWAY SO WE'LL BE RIGHT BACK
AS SOON AS WE HAVE AN AUTHOR IN
THE ROOM. THANK YOU
. PAUSE WE
ALMOST HAVE A QUORUM BUT WE
HAVE AN AUTHOR HERE'S SENATOR
ARE TO LET IS GOING TO PRESENT
SB FOUR EIGHTY. WOULD LIKE TO
WELCOME ME WE'RE GONNA MEET AS
A COMMITTEE OF THE WHOLE WE
HAVE ONE MORE MEMBER. SHORT AND
THEN WILL CALL A QUORUM AND THE
OFFICIALS SO SENATOR ARHULETA
WELCOME. GOOD THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR. I AM. PLEASED YUBA. CITY
HERE DIDN'T REALIZE WE'RE GONNA
DO IT RIGHT OFF THE BAT BUT I
AM HONORED- THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR TODAY I'M HERE TO-
PRESENT SB FOUR EIGHTY- I WANT
TO BEGIN BY THANKING. THE
COMMITTEE THE STAFF FOR THEIR
DILIGENT WORK ON THIS BILL AND
BY ACCEPTING THE TECHNICAL
AMENDMENTS. AND WITH THOSE
AMENDMENTS I THINK IT OPEN THE
DOOR TO CONTINUE ON. AS AMENDED
THIS BILL ESTABLISH AN ADVISORY
COMMITTEE. TO EVALUATE WHAT
STEPS CALIFORNIA CAN TAKE. TO
HELP IMPROVE THE LICENSURE OF
ADVANCED PRACTICE RADIOLOGICAL
TECHNICIANS. AND I CARRY THIS
BILL BECAUSE MANY OF OUR
VETERANS AND TRANSITIONING BACK
INTO THE CIVILIAN WORLD. HAVE
TRAINED PARTICIPATED IN THEIR
WORLD OF THAT WHICH CALLED
THEIR M. O. S. THEIR MILITARY
OCT. OCCUPATIONAL SPECIALTIES
WHICH EXCEEDS. IN SOME CASES
TRADITIONAL TECHNICIANS
TRAINING. THE ADVISORY
COMMITTEE ESTABLISHES- AND THAT
IT IS SEVENTH BY THIS BILL WILL
EVALUATE WHAT IS BEING DONE IN
CALIFORNIA IN THIS SPACE AND
WHAT CAN BE DONE TO HELP MEET
THE EVER INCREASING DEMANDS FOR
MEDICAL SERVICES THROUGHOUT THE
STATE. ADVANCE CARE TECHNICIANS
IN RADIOLOGY ARE RECOGNIZED
OVER THIRTY STATES THROUGHOUT
THE COUNTRY. BY IMPLEMENTING
FURTHER STUDY INTO HOW
CALIFORNIA CAN BEST RECOGNIZES
PRACTICE NOT ONLY DO WE CREATE
FURTHER OPPORTUNITIES FOR THE
PUBLIC TO RECEIVE HEALTH CARE
SERVICES BUT WE CAN ALSO CREATE
ENVIRONMENT THAT IS WELCOME TO
OUR VETERANS AND IN TODAY'S
WORLD WITH THEIR TRAINING AND
EXPERTISE WE NEED ALL THE
VETERANS TO PARTICIPATE. MANY
VETERANS HAVE BEEN ADVANCED
RADIOLOGICAL TRAINING THAT CAN
HELP TOWARDS WORKING IN THIS
SPACE AS A TRANSITION BACK INTO
CIVILIAN LIFE. I HOPE THIS
ADVISORY COMMITTEE FINDS
ADDITIONAL ACTIONABLE DATA THAT
CALIFORNIA CAN USE TO HELP
VETERANS AND SEMINARY TRAINED
CIVILIANS GOOD WERE NOT
ELIMINATING CIVILIANS TO HAVE
THEM ALSO OBTAIN LICENSURE IN
THIS EXPANDING MEDICAL PRACTICE
CALIFORNIA CAN ONLY BENEFIT
WITH THESE INDIVIDUALS LIVE AND
WORK AND OUR STATE. WITH ME
TODAY I HAVE TERRY MCHALE
REPRESENTING THE AMERICAN
REGISTRY OF RADIOLOGICAL
TECHNOLOGIST AND BOB ACKERMAN
REPRESENTED THE CALIFORNIA
RADIOLOGICAL SOCIETY WHO ARE
HERE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL I CAN ALSO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS THAT YOU MAY HAVE. IN
THE TECHNICAL SIDE WHICH I'M
SURE YOU WILL HAVE. DILLON IT
IS JUST A FEW THANK YOU MISTER
ARCHULETA AND I'M AT ALL PAUSE
FOR JUST A MOMENT TO FOR TWO
PURPOSES ONE WE'RE GOING TO
ESTABLISH A CHORUS OF YOU HOLD
ON FOR SECRETARY CALL THE ROLL
GLAZER HERE GLAZER HERE CHIANG
HERE CHIANG HERE ARE TO LET UP
HERE. TO LET HERE DODD GALGIANI
HILL YOUR HILL HERE LEYVA.
LEYVA HERE PAN THERE CAN HEAR
WELL. OKAY SO WE HAVE A QUORUM.
LET ME MENTION TO- THE SENATOR
AND HIS WITNESSES AND TO THOSE
WHO WILL. FOLLOW THAT WE DO
HAVE A PRACTICE HERE AND THE
BUSINESS AND PROFESSIONS AND
ALLOWING. TWO WITNESSES ON EACH
SIDE TWO MINUTES EACH AND THEN
WE AT ENCOURAGING THOSE WHO
SHARE YOUR VIEW TO. COME TO THE
MICROPHONE AND IDENTIFY
THEMSELVES INTO A ME TOO
WITHOUT TESTIMONY SO WITHOUT I
WELCOME YOUR TWO WITNESSES
CENTER ARCHER. AND I'LL HAVE
THEM INTRODUCE THEMSELVES AND-
WILL DO THAT INDIVIDUALLY. WE
WILL START WITH MY RIGHT. IN MY
LIFE. MISTER CHAIRMAN TERRY
MCHALE WITH THEIR AND READ
NECESSITY IT'S GOOD MORNING-
REPRESENTING THE AMERICAN
REGISTRY RADIOLOGICAL
TECHNOLOGIST OF THE
RADIOLOGICAL SYSTEM WAS CREATED
BY THE MILITARY IN THE NINETEEN
SEVENTIES WHEN THERE IS A
DEARTH OF RADIOLOGISTS. THEY
ARE ALLOWED TO DO MORE THAN
THE- BRADY WAS ALLOWED BEFORE
THEY CAN DO X. RAY UNITS FOREST
COPIC SYSTEMS MAMMOGRAPHY MRI.
THE RECOGNIZED IN THIRTY SIX
STATES FOR THEIR ABILITY TO DO
IT IN THIS WHILE WE WANTED TO
DO SUNSET WE DID LISTEN TO YOUR
COMMITTEE WE DEFERRED TO YOUR
STAFF. AND BELIEVE THAT THIS-
THIS THIS WAY OF DOING THE
RESEARCH MAKES BETTER SENSE IN
THE OLD DAYS WE USED TO DO THE-
OFSTED REPORTS AND THEY WOULD
END UP BEING FOUGHT OVER-ANYWAY. THIS THIS BRINGS PEOPLE
TOGETHER EVEN WITH THE SPIRIT
VIEWS AND IT'S CONSTRUCTIVE
PRODUCTIVE AND IT WORKS THANK
YOU. THIS IS YOUR NUMBERS BY
BACK THEN WITH THE CALIFORNIA
RADIOLOGICAL SOCIETY SO
PHYSICIANS AT RETAIL TO
POSITIONS ARE COLLABORATING
WITH. THE R. TEASE IN THIS
EXPANDED ROLE IT'S BEEN
SOMETHING THAT'S BEEN THIS IS
BUSINESS MR CALE OF THE AUTHOR
INDICATED. HAS BEEN AROUND FOR
A NUMBER OF DECADES A NUMBER OF
STATES. THE VOLUME OF IMAGING
CONTINUES TO INCREASE THE NEEDS
OF RADIOLOGISTS IN TERMS OF THE
PROCEDURES THEY DO. AN MRI
THESE DAYS CAN GENERATE
HUNDREDS OF IMAGES THAT IN A
POSITION HAS TO REVIEW SO. THAT
ARE A COULD BE USEFUL IN
ASSUMING SOME OF THE
RESPONSIBILITIES THAT WOULD
ALLOW THE RADIOLOGIST A FOCUS
ON IMAGING. AND THE STUDIES AND
INTERPRETATIONS AND WITH
TRAINING AND EXPERIENCE THESE
INDIVIDUALS WITHOUT VERY
VALUABLE- IN IMAGING PRACTICE-
IT'S ONE OF THOSE SITUATIONS IF
YOU BUILD IT THEY WILL COME
THERE'S NO ABILITY FOR THESE
FOR THESE INDIVIDUALS TO.
REALLY BE USED IN CALIFORNIATO
THEIR FULL TRAINING AND
COMPETENCY. SO WE'RE LOOKING
FOR A PATH FORWARD THIS BILL
SETS UP THAT MECHANISM
APPRECIATE. THE CHAIR AND STAFF
IN THE AUTHOR LOOKING FOR
ALTERNATIVES HERE- AND LOOK
FORWARD TO FINDING A PATH
FORWARD. VERY GOOD THANK YOU
FOR YOUR WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
ANYBODY ELSE WHO WISHES TO
IDENTIFY IN FAVOR THIS BILL
COULD YOU COME UP TO THE
MICROPHONE AND- SO IDENTIFY.
THE BODY ELSE. OKAY ARE THERE
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
AFTERNOON GOOD AFTERNOON OR
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE OCCURS
LANE JUNIOR WITH THE CALIFORNIA
NURSES ASSOCIATION I THANK YOU
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK ON
BEHALF OF OVER A HUNDRED
THOUSAND REGISTERED NURSES IN
CALIFORNIA A CNA OPPOSES SB
FOUR EIGHTY OF THE
ESTABLISHMENT OF A RADIOLOGY
ASSISTING COMMITTEE TO RESEARCH
AND RECOMMEND POTENTIAL
STATUTORY CHANGES TO GRANT
EXPANDING PRACTICE OF THE
ALREADY THE CERTIFIED RADIOLOGY
TECHNICIANS OR MEDICAL
ASSISTANCE AS PROPOSED IN SB
FOUR EIGHTY. THE MEDICAL BOARD
OF CALIFORNIA CURRENTLY PASSED
THE AUTHORITY TO ADOPT AND
ADMINISTER REGULATIONS THAT
ESTABLISH STANDARDS FOR
TECHNICAL SUPPORT OF SERVICES
THAT MAY BE PERFORMED. BY A
LICENSED MEDICAL ASSISTANT
THESE REGULATORY CHANGES DO NOT
REQUIRE ADDITIONAL STATUTORY
AUTHORITY. SB FOUR EIGHTY
POSITS THE TWELVE MEMBER
RADIOLOGY ASSISTING COMMITTEE
WITH THE RESPONSIBILITY OF
DETERMINING THE APPROPRIATENESS
OF SPECIALTY MEDICAL SYSTEM
LICENSOR OF NICK OCCUPATION
THAT IS CURRENTLY UNLICENSED-
IN CNA CONTENDS THAT UNLICENSED
MEDICAL ASSISTANCE WHO DESIRE
TO PERFORM ADDITIONAL FUNCTIONS
IN RADIOLOGY SHOULD BE
SUPPORTED. AND GAINING
EDUCATIONAL TRAINING TOWARDS
CERTIFICATION BY THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH AS
A RADIOLOGY TECHNICIAN. WE ALSO
QUESTION THE NASA NECESSITY OF
CREATING A NEW LICENSE OR
CATEGORY FOR RADIOLOGY
ASSISTANCE AND ARE CONCERNED
THAT THE INTRODUCTION OF A NEW
TYPE OF PRACTITIONER WILL LEAD
TO A MORE FRAGMENTED SYSTEM OF
CARE FOR RADIOLOGY PATIENTS. WE
ADVOCATE FOR THE HIGHEST
STANDARDS OF CARE FOR PATIENTS
AND HAVE STRONG CONCERNS WITH
ANY MEASURE THAT AIMS TO
ESTABLISH NEW LICENSOR.
CATEGORIES FOR HEALING ARTS PER
PRACTITIONERS FOR THESE REASONS
CNA AS OPPOSED TO ASK BEFORE
EIGHTY AS AMENDED AND WE
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR NO
VOTE ON THIS BILL. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MISTER LANG ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION. JUST
ONE MOMENT THIS GET THE
MICROPHONE WORKING. THE RAIN
SPENCER WITH AMERICAN COLLEGE
OBGYN STRYCHNINE WE WERE
OPPOSED TO THE PREVIOUS VERSION
OF THIS BILL THEY HAVE A- THE
ECARD HAS BEEN LOOKING AT THIS
EXISTING VERSION AFTER CHRIS
REVIEW THEY DO HAVE SOME
CONCERNS WITH THE MAKE UP OF
THE WORKING GROUP- THERE THEY
RECOGNIZE THAT RADIOLOGISTS ARE
GOING FOR THIS GROUP THAT ARE
INCLUDED. I THINK THEY WOULD
LIKE TO INCLUDE AS WELL AS
OTHER PHYSICIAN GROUPS AT LEAST
BE CONSIDERED FOR INCLUSION SO
WITH A FOUR TO WORK WITH THE
AUTHOR AND THE SPONSORS AND
APPRECIATE THE COMMITTEE'S WORK
ON THIS CURRENT VERSION I'M
SORRY NOW WE DON'T HAVE
ADDITIONAL THIS ONE BE WITH THE
FORD WORKING WITH PRESS TO BE
ALL THANK YOU. VERY GOOD ANY
OTHER. SPEAKERS IN OPPOSITION.
ALL RIGHT WE'RE GONNA BRING THE
MATTER BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
FOR QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS. LET
ME JUST MAKE A NOTE FROM BAD
PRACTICE. BEST PRACTICES IN OUR
COMMITTEE- SAID IF YOU HAVE A
POSITION ON A BILL TO COOLEY IF
YOU'RE IN OPPOSITION TO PUT A
RECORD- PUT OUT A LETTER ON
RECORD- SO WE I ALWAYS
APPRECIATE THAT I KNOW THE
AUTHORS DO AS WELL AND- NEVER-
EASY TO COME INTO A HEARING AND
LEARN ABOUT OPPOSITION FOR THE
FIRST TIME. I DO NOT THAT THIS
BILL WAS AMENDED. FAIRLY
RECENTLY AND SO. THAT'S A
CONSIDERATION THAT I KNOW IS
CHALLENGING FOR MANY. ALL RIGHT
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM THE
COMMITTEE. THE BILL. I SEE NO
FURTHER QUESTIONS THAT CENTER
ARCH LETTER WE LIKE TO CLOSE
YES THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS I WANT TO
THANK THE CHAIR AGAIN FOR-
LOOKING INTO THE AMENDMENTS AS
MUCH AS HE HAS AND THE STAFF
WITH THE AMENDMENTS I THINK WE
CAN GO FORWARD I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE VERY GOOD
THANK YOU AND- I'M HAPPY TO
SUPPORT YOUR BILL TODAY SENATOR
THANK YOU FOR YOUR WORK ON IT I
THINK THE- THE INTERIM STEP IN
WHICH YOU SUGGEST IN THIS THAT
LEGISLATION FOR THIS TASK FORCE
SEEMS LIKE A- A CAREFUL
CAUTIOUS ONE I KNOW THAT YOUR-
OPPONENTS WOULD LIKE TO GO MUCH
FURTHER BUT IT SEEMS LIKE
AFTER. A PRUDENT STEP TO ME ON
THAT RECOGNIZE THE MOTION FOR
SENATOR PAN TO MOVE THE BILL.
AS AMENDED. THE SECRETARY CALL
THE ROLL. MISSION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
GLAZER AYE GLAZER AYE CHIANG
MAI. CHIANG AYE ARCHULETA. AYE
PARTULA AYE DODD. DODD AYE
GALGIANI. GALGIANI AYE HILL.
HILL AYE LEYVA. LIVE AYE PAN
PAN I WILL. LOOK AT. RIGHT AT
THAT BILL IS IN NINE ZERO
CONGRADULATIONS THAT BILLS OUT
CENTER SKINNER THANK YOU FOR
YOUR PATIENCE IN WAITING FOR
YOUR BILL TO BE HEARD I'D LIKE
TO INVITE YOU TO COME FORWARD.
THIS IS THE ITEM NUMBER THREE.
SB SIX NINETY TWO BY CENTER
SKINNER. PLEASE COME ON UP.
WITH. MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
APPRECIATE THE BEEN ABLE TO
PRESENT SB SIX NINETY TWO VERY
COMPARABLE BILL PASSED OUT OF
COMMITTEE LAST YEAR- HOWEVER
THE SPONSORS AND I DECIDED TO
HOLD THAT COMPARABLE BILL LAST
YEAR BECAUSE THE ADMINISTRATION
IS YOU KNOW WE HAVE THE OFFICE
THAT. DEVELOPS REGULATIONS FOR
CANNABIS WAS RELATIVELY NEW WE
STILL IN THE MIDDLE OF A LOT OF
PROCESS HE'S AND WE WANTED TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE WERE ALIGNING
WHATEVER- WORK WE WERE DOING ON
TRYING TO MAKE TRADE SAMPLES
AVAILABLE ALIGNED WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION'S OWN THE- THE
CANNABIS ROLES IN REX SO WE
KNEW THAT THEY WERE TOO BUSY
LAST YEAR TO REALLY ENGAGE WITH
US TO MAKE SURE THAT WE WERE-
WE'RE ON THE SAME PAGE SO
THAT'S WHY WE HELD IT AND
THAT'S WHY IT'S REINTRODUCED
AND BEFORE YOU TODAY. SO
BASICALLY WHAT THE BILL
ADDRESSES IS THE FACT THAT
WHILE IN IN ALMOST EVERY OTHER
CATEGORY OF A RETAIL A
MANUFACTURE DISTRIBUTION
WHATEVER THERE ARE TRADE
SAMPLES NOW WE'RE NOT TALKING
ABOUT TRADE SAMPLES FOR THE
PUBLIC WE'RE NOT TALKING ABOUT
LIKE GOING TO COSTCO AND
SOMEBODY'S GOING TO GIVE YOU A
SAMPLE OF SOME CANNABIS PRODUCT
NO IT'S PURELY IN THE SAME WAY
THAT WHETHER IT'S IN A
PRESCRIPTION TRADE WHATEVER
TRADE WHEN A DISTRIBUTOR OR
MANUFACTURER GOES TO THE
RETAILER. THEY ARE ABLE TO
ALLOW THEIR PRODUCT TO BE
SAMPLED TO SEE IF THAT RETAILER
FOR THAT PRODUCT MEETS THE FOR
WHAT THEY BELIEVE THEIR
CUSTOMERS NEEDS ARE SO WHAT
THIS BILL WOULD DO IS ALLOW FOR
THAT WITHIN THE CANNABIS
INDUSTRY AGAIN VERY LIMITED IT
WOULD BE A VERY LIMITED NUMBER
OF SAMPLES THAT WOULD EVER BE
ABLE TO GET EXCHANGED AND AGAIN
THROUGH I NEVER THROUGH TO THE
CUSTOMERS ONLY TO. BE LICENSED
RETAILER. AS IN THE LICENSE
DISTRIBUTORS SO THAT'S ITS
PURPOSE AND I'M ALLOW BY. A
INDUSTRY PRESENTERS OF GOT
MICHAEL WHEELER FROM FLOW KANA
IN AMY JENKINS FROM THE
CANNABIS INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION
WITNESSES VERY GOOD CENTER AND
USED- YO ACCEPTING THE
TECHNICAL AMENDMENT THE
ANALYSIS YES I AM IN THANK YOU
APOLOGIES FOR NOT FIGHTING WITH
THAT NO PROBLEM AT ALL AND
THANK YOU FOR YOUR- REMARKS AND
WE WELCOME YOUR WITNESSES. TWO
MINUTES EACH. GOOD AFTERNOON
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY
NAME IS MICHAEL WHEELER I'M THE
VICE PRESIDENT OF POLICY
INITIATIVES THAT FLOW KANA FOR
CON IS A REGULATED CANNABIS
SUPPLY CHAIN COMPANY- AS
MENTION THIS CONCEPT WAS
APPROVED BY THIS COMMITTEE LAST
YEAR UNDER THE BILL NUMBER SB
FOUR SEVENTY FIVE. THE
SOLUTIONS THIS BILL PROVIDES TO
THE CANNABIS INDUSTRY REGARDING
BUSINESS TO BUSINESS TRADE
SAMPLES. ARE ONLY GREATER THIS
YEAR I AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
AGAIN FOR YOUR AYE VOTE THANK
YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT
WITNESS MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS AMY JENKINS ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA CANNABIS
INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION. FIVE
HUNDRED MEMBERS STRONG
ASSOCIATION REPRESENTING ALL
ASPECTS OF THE INDUSTRY THIS
TRULY IS ONE OF OUR TOP
PRIORITIES AND WE APPLIED THE
SENATOR FOR HER LEADERSHIP AND-
HER EFFORTS TO ADVANCE THIS.
ISSUE THIS YEAR JUST TWO QUICK
POINTS ALL MAKE THIS REALLY
WILL ALLOW FOR GREATER EXPOSURE
FOR SMALL AND EMERGING CANNABIS
BUSINESSES THEY REALLY NEED
ADDITIONAL SUPPORT. THIS WILL
PROVIDE THAT AVENUE AND IT WILL
REALLY IMPROVE CONSUMER
OUTCOMES- OUR RETAILERS NEED TO
KNOW- WHAT THESE PRODUCTS DO
WHAT THEY'RE AFFECTS ARE SO
THEY CAN BETTER INFORM AND
EDUCATE MEDICINAL PATIENTS AND
CONSUMERS. FOR THESE REASONS
AND MANY MORE AND WE STRONGLY
SUPPORT THE BILL AND ARE PROUD
CO SPONSORS THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH ARE THERE OTHER
WITNESSES WHO LIKE TO DO A ME
TOO WITH THE MICROPHONE COME ON
UP. ALICIA PRIEGO HERE ON
BEHALF OF EASE IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU. RAND MARTIN ON BEHALF OF
WHAT PER LOGISTICS AND CMG
KHALIFA IN STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. NORWOOD ON BEHALF OF
THE CANNABIS DISTRIBUTION
ASSOCIATION STRONG SUPPORT.
HELLO SOLELY SOME HAVE REUNITED
KIND OF HAS BEEN ASSOCIATION
STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
MORTGAGE JASON BROWN HALF THE
COUPLE COUNTY GROWERS ALLIANCE
WERE SUPPORTIVE AMENDED TO THE
BILL WE'D LIKE TO SEE
AMENDMENTS IN THE- NEXT
ITERATION OF THE BUILD UP FOR
THE SAME OPPORTUNITIES BY TO
DISTRIBUTORS AND RETAILERS ALSO
TO MANUFACTURERS AND
CULTIVATORS TO BE ABLE TO.
SAMPLE THEIR PRODUCTS WITHIN
THE SUPPLY CHAIN SO LONG AS
THEY'RE TESTED WE'VE OFFERED
THOSE MINUTES OF THE AUTHOR AND
THE SPONSORS AND WE LOOK FOR TO
WORK WITH THEM. THANK YOU THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. GOOD AFTERNOON
MR TURN RISK ISN'T IN TRACI
STEELE ON BEHALF OF NATURE ALSO
IN STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU
CHAIR MEMBERS TING A FEW ON
BEHALF OF THE SENATE CALIFORNIA
COALITION IN SUPPORT OF SB SIX
I TO THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH ARE THERE ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION. ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION. ALL RIGHT VERY GOOD
WILL I BRING THE MATTER BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS MEMBERS ANY QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS FOR THE AUTHORS A
SENATOR PAN. S. ONE QUICK
QUESTION THE- SAMPLES ARE JUST
BETWEEN THE DISTRIBUTORS AND
RESELLERS NOT TO THE PUBLIC BUT
IS AND I UNDERSTAND FROM
ANALYSIS IT'S FOR ACTUALLY
EDUCATION- SO A LET'S SAY A
DISTRIBUTOR ONCE A CHAU
RETAILER WHAT THERE BE IS IT IS
SELLING IT IT IS THE IS THE
SAMPLE AND TENDED BE CONSUMED
IN ANYWAY I MEAN I GET THE IDEA
OF LIKE HERE'S A SAMPLE SO YOU
KNOW WHAT LOOKS LIKE AN HOUSE
PACKAGE AND SO FORTH- OTHER. IS
IT IS RIGHT. THAT THAT THE
SAMPLE IS. TO BE USED IT IS TO
BE CONSUMED IN ANYWHERE WELL
THAT IS OBVIOUSLY. IN THE WAY
THE BILLS SIGN UP TO THE
RETAILER. BUT I WOULD IMAGINE
THAT IN SOME CASES SOME
RETAILERS MAY WANT TO BECAUSE
IF FOR EXAMPLE- AS WE KNOW. IT
TEARS- PRODUCTS CAN HAVE A
RANGE OF CBT IN THC. LEVELS.
AND RATIOS THESE CAN HAVE. THIS
THE WHOLE NOTION OF EVEN UNDER
RECREATIONAL USE HOW PSYCHO
ACTIVE THE- THE PARTICULAR-
PRODUCT IS- CAN BE BASED ON
THOSE RATIOS OR ON THE- THE-
ORIGIN OF THE PARTICULAR
CANNABIS- VARIETY. AND. YOU
MEAN AGAIN I'M NOT SURE IF ALL
OF M COLLEAGUES HERE HAVE.
GONE TO A DISPENSARY WORRY
CANNABIS RETAIL AND WHEN
OFTENTIMES YOU MAY BE LOOKING
FOR SOMETHING THAT IS A
RECREATIONAL BUT VERY LOW
PSYCHOACTIVE AND YOU COULD BE
TALKING YOUR YOUR BASED LEAD
YOU'RE TALKING TO THAT PERSON
AT THE COUNTER TRYING TO GET
INFORMATION YOU DON'T WANT TO
JUST GO BUY A TEN PRODUCTS AND
GO HOME AND BE YOURSELF THE
GUINEA PIG. AND YOU'RE HOPING
THAT THAT A PERSON BEHIND THE
COUNTER HAS THE INFORMATION WAS
SOMETIMES THAT DOES REQUIRE THE
RETAILER TO HAVE TRIED IT SO
THERE'S NOT A RESTRICTION ON
THAT IN THE BILL BUT THESE YOU
NOTICE IT IS RESTRICTED ON THE
AMOUNT THAT COULD BE. PASSED IN
THAT WAY. VERY GOOD ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS. SIR WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE. YES I THINK WE'VE
BEEN HAVE A GOOD DISCUSSION
AND- WE ARE OBVIOUSLY TALKING
TO THE. THE MANUFACTURERS AND
THE CULTIVATORS AROUND WHETHER
BECAUSE IN MOST TRADE SAMPLES
IT IS A BROADER THAN JUST THE
DISTRIBUTOR AND RETAILER SO WE
ARE HAVING THOSE CONVERSATIONS
BUT WE HAVE NOTHING TO WE HAVE
NO AT WE'RE NOT BRING FORTY
MINUTE TODAY. AND WITH THAT I
WOULD READ EXT RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE WITH THE
TECHNICAL AMENDMENTS VERY GOOD
CENTER SKINNER IS BROUGHT A
BILL TO US WELL AND ACCEPTED
THE TECHNICAL AMENDMENTS IN THE.
A STAFF REPORT IS THERE A
MOTION SENATOR HILL IS MOVE THE
BILL SO WITH THAT. INVITE THE
ODDS SECRETARY TO CALL THE
ROLL. MISSION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED THE SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE GLAZER
AYE GLAZER AYE CHIANG CHING AYE
ARCHULETA. ARCHULETA AYE DODD
AYE DODD AYE GALGIANI GALGIANI
AYE HILL. HILL AYE LEYVA LIVE
AYE PAN. LOOK LOOK I. ZERO ALL
RIGHT THAT BILL IS OUT EIGHT
ZERO THANK YOU VERY MUCH
SENATOR. ALL RIGHT. I THINK
THAT COMPLETES OUR AGENDA TODAY.
JEFF OKAY- YES WE HAVE ONE MORE
BILL I'M SO SORRY. I MUST OF.
BY THAT WE WANT TO INVITE TO
ITEM NUMBER ONE- SB TO ALIGN
CENTER WIENER WELCOME TO THE
COMMITTEE
. HI HOW ARE YOU I
YEAH YEAH. IF. OKAY CENTER WE
ARE ALL SET YES OKAY VERY GOOD
WELCOME. I THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN AND ON COLLEAGUES FOR
HER IN THIS BILL TODAY- THIS
BILL WAS BEFORE THE COMMITTEE
BACK AND- THIS DOES FOR THE
COMMITTEE BACK IN APRIL AND-
THE CHAIR ASKED FOR TO BE TO
YOUR BILL AND SO. THAT'S THE
DIRECTION WE WENT AND WE'RE
BACK BEFORE THE COMMITTEE.
SENATE BILL TO A ONE ON IS
ABOUT BASIC CIVIL AND HUMAN
RIGHTS. ARE THE RIGHT FOR
PEOPLE TO MAKE FUNDAMENTAL
CHOICES ABOUT THEIR OWN BODY.
HI THIS LEGISLATION WILL ENSURE
THAT PEOPLE WHO WERE BORN
INTERSEX ARE ABLE TO MAKE THEIR
OWN CHOICES ABOUT THEIR HEALTH.
AND THEIR GENDER IDENTITY
INSTEAD OF HAVING OTHER PEOPLE
MAKE THOSE YOUR REVERSIBLE
SURGICAL CHOICES FOR ABOUT. IF
YOU CAN IMAGINE HAVING A
MEDICALLY UNNECESSARY PROCEDURE
ON YOUR BODY WHAT DO YOU WANT
TO HAVE SOME INPUT INTO WHETHER
THAT HAPPENS AS OPPOSED TO
HAVING OTHER PEOPLE. MAKE THOSE
DECISIONS FOR YOU BEFORE YOU
EVEN HAVE THE PHYSICAL CAPACITY
TO BE ABLE TO HAVE INPUT
BECAUSE BABIES CAN'T TALK. TO
BE CLEAR SENATE BILL TO A ONE
IS NOT ABOUT REMOVING PARENTS
WERE PHYSICIANS FROM THE
DECISION WHETHER OR NOT TO HAVE
SURGERY PARENTS ORDER AND
POSITIONS UNDER THIS BILL WILL
CONTINUE TO HAVE THAT
INVOLVEMENT. INDEED PARENTS
WILL CONTINUE TO MAKE THE FINAL
DECISION. BUT RIGHT NOW THE
ONLY PERSON WHO IS NOT INVOLVED
IN THE DECISION IF THE PERSON
WHOSE BODY IS BEING PERMANENTLY
CHANGE IRREVERSIBLY CHANGE.
WHAT WE'RE SAYING UNDER THE
AMENDMENT SO WE JUST PUT INTO
THIS BILL THIS WEEK. IS THAT
LET'S WAIT UNTIL SIX YEARS OLD.
WHEN THAT CHILD CAN AT LEAST
PARTICIPATE IN THE DECISION AND
HELP INFORM PARENTS DECISION
ABOUT WHAT GENDER THE CHILD
IDENTIFIES WITH. AND WHETHER%
THAT CHILD WANTS TO HAVE
MEDICALLY UNNECESSARY- A
SURGERY IN ORDER TO CHANGE AND
RECONSTRUCT THEIR GENITALS. ALL
WE'RE ASKING COLLEAGUES IS FOR
THE PERSON IMPACTED TO ACTUALLY
BE ABLE TO PARTICIPATE IN THE
DECISION WHEN YOU OPERATE ON A
BABY. THAT PERSON CANNOT
PARTICIPATE. AND TO BE CLEAR WE
ARE TALKING ABOUT MEDICALLY
UNNECESSARY SURGERIES ONLY WE
ARE NOT TALKING ABOUT
SITUATIONS WHERE THERE IS A
MEDICAL PROBLEM THERE WAS A
WITNESS LAST APRIL WHO CAME MEN.
AND SHE TESTIFIED ABOUT HOW SHE
WAS SATISFIED WITH THE SURGERY.
SHE HAS CAN GENERAL ADRENAL
HYPERPLASIA AND WHEN SHE
EXPLINS. THE PROBLEMS THE SHE
WAS EXPERIENCE AS A BABY THAT
SHE COULDN'T URINATE THAT IS A
MEDICAL CONDITION AND THIS BILL
WOULD NOT PRECLUDE THAT KIND OF
SURGERY WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
PERFECTLY HEALTHY BABIES WHO DO
NOT HAVE A HEALTH PROBLEM. BUT
THEIR GENITALIA DO NOT CONFORM
WITH WHAT WE CONSIDER TO BE
TYPICAL AND SO THERE IS AN
EFFORT TO QUOTE ON QUOTE
NORMALIZE THE LOCK. I WANT TO
TRUST- COMMENT- ON THE KID AND
WE PREFER SO I WANT TO THANK
THE CHAIR AND HIS STAFF FOR
HAVING A VERY OPEN DOOR TO US
OVER THE PAST YEAR WE HAVEN'T
ALWAYS AGREED ON EVERYTHING-
BUT THE CHAIR AND THE STAFF
HAVE BEEN VERY GENEROUS WITH
THEIR TIME BOTH TO ME AND TO MY
STAFF. AND TO OUR COALITION AND
WE VERY MUCH APPRECIATE THE
ABILITY- TO HAVE THAT DIALOGUE
I DO HOWEVER NEED TO
RESPECTFULLY DISAGREE WITH A
FEW ASPECTS OF THE COMMITTEE-
AND ANALYSIS- FIRST OF ALL THE
IN ALICE'S SAYS THAT ARE THE
DEFINITION SB TWO OH ONE OF
INTER SOCKS. IS SOMEHOW
INCONSISTENT WITH OTHER
DEFINITIONS- WE DON'T AGREE
WITH THAT THIS DEFINITION IS
CONSISTENT WITH THE UNITED
NATIONS DEFINITION AND THE
DEFINITION- AS PUT FORWARD BY
EVERY MAJOR INTERSEX GROUP IN
THE WORLD. ON THE V. BUT THE
HOUSE IS ALSO FOR- FOCUSES ON
CHROMOSOMES WHETHER YOU'RE AX
AX OR AXE WHITE. HI AND FRANKLY
THIS ANALYSIS COULD HAVE BEEN
WRITTEN WITH EVER EVEN WITHOUT
EVER EVEN MENTIONING THE
CONCEPT OF CHROMOSOMES BECAUSE
CHROMOSOMES OR 1100% RELEVANT
TO GENDER. AND WE SEE THAT WITH
TRANSGENDER PEOPLE. PEOPLE WHO
ARE BORN LET'S SAY AXE WHITE
WITH A LET'S SAY A **** THAT.
BERKELEY CONFORMS TO WHAT ODDS
WITH SOCIETY THINGS APPEARS TO
LOOK LIKE. AND A PERSON BY THE
AGE OF FIVE IS IDENTIFYING AS A
GIRL. ROOM ISMS ARE IRRELEVANT
THE WAY THE GENERAL'S LOOK ARE
RELEVANT TO SOMEONE'S GENDER
AND WE SEE THAT. WITH THE
TRANSGENDER COMMUNITY WHICH IS
WHY THIS LEGISLATURE HAS
OVERWHELMINGLY PASSED THE BILL
AFTER BILL TO PROTECT
TRANSGENDER PEOPLE BECAUSE WE
DON'T SAY THAT WE LOOK ONLY AT
YOUR CHROMOSOMES ARE HOW YOUR
GENITALS LOOK TO THE SIDE. WHAT
GENDER YOU ARE AND WHETHER YOU
SHOULD HAVE SURGERY TO
RECONSTRUCT YOUR GENITALS IN A
MEDICALLY UNNECESSARY WAY
BECAUSE OF WHAT YOUR
CHROMOSOMES ARE OR WHAT YOUR
GENERALS. LOOK LIKE. THE
SUGGESTIONS IN THE ANALYSIS
DIAGNOSIS IS NOT PUT FORWARD
AMENDMENTS BUT THERE ARE
SUGGESTIONS OF. WHAT
AMENDMENTS. COULD BE- IF WE
WERE TO GO IN THAT DIRECTION
MORE THAN 80% OF INTERSEX
PEOPLE WOULD BE REMOVED FROM
THE PROTECTIONS OF THIS BILL.
ON FOR MUCH OF HUMAN HISTORY
PEOPLE WHO WERE BORN INTERSEX
WHICH IS LEFT ALONE. BASIS LIVE
THEIR LIVES AND THAT WAS THAT.
IT WAS IN THE NINETEEN FIFTIES
OF THE MEDICAL PROFESSION
DECIDED THAT WE NEEDED TO
PERFORM MEDICALLY ON
NECESSARILY SURGERIES TO QUOTE
UNQUOTE NORMALIZE THESE
CHILDREN. THE SURGERIES THREE
VERY CLEAR ARE VERY INVASIVE
AND RISKY SURGERIES IS
RECONSTRUCTING SOMEONE'S
GENITALS. ACOSTA CAN CAUSE
PERMANENT STERILIZATION
PERMANENT LOSS OF SEXUAL
SENSATION FOR THE REST OF THEIR
LIVES YOUR REVERSIBLE.
PERMANENT URINARY TRACT ISSUES.
AND THESE ARE SERIOUS POTENTIAL
SIDE EFFECTS AND THAT'S WHY IT
IS APART FROM ANY ISSUE OF
GENDER. SOMEONE SHOULD BE ABLE
TO HAVE INPUT ABOUT WHETHER
THEY'RE GOING TO HAVE THAT KIND
OF MEDICALLY UNNECESSARY
SURGERY THAT COULD HAVE
PROFOUND NEGATIVEIMPACTS ON
THEM FOR THE REST OF THEIR
LIVES AND YET THEY HAD NO
OPPORTUNITY TO SAY WHETHER THEY
WANTED TO HAVE THAT SURGERY.
AND WHAT OTHER CIRCUMSTANCES
WOULD WE ALLOW THAT TO HAPPEN
THE CALIFORNIA RESIDENTS. IN
ADDITION. AND SEPARATE FROM NOT
BROADER ISSUE. WE KNOW THAT THE
WRONG GENDER CAN BE A SIGN.
THAT A DAUGHTER COULD SAY WELL
YOUR AXE WHY AND THIS SEEMS
LIKE IT'S MORE LIKE A **** AND
A **** SO WE'RE JUST GONNA
RECONSTRUCTED AND MAKE IT INTO
A **** OR VICE VERSA. AND THEN
A FEW YEARS LATE LATER THE KID
SAYS BUT I'M A GIRL. WELL YOU
CAN'T FIX IT THEN. MAYBE YOU
CAN MAYBE POTENTIALLY A LITTLE
BIT. BUT THAT IS A PERMANENT
IRREVERSIBLE DECISION THAT WAS
MADE FOR THAT CHILD NOT CHAO'S
CAN HAVE TO LIVE WITH THAT FOR
THE REST OF THEIR LIFE. EVEN
THOUGH THEY HAD NO INPUT
WHATSOEVER. NOW WE HAVE MADE
AMENDMENTS TO THE BILL THIS
WEEK- HOW WE SCALE BACK ARE THE
BILL AROUND SOME- WHAT WERE
CONSIDERED POTENTIALLY GRAY
AREAS AROUND HYPOSPADIAS ONE OF
THE CONDITIONS WE LISTENED AND
WE HEARD. AND WE MADE SOME
CHANGES. IN ADDITION ORIGINALLY
THE BILL SAID YOU CAN'T PERFORM
THE SURGERY UNTIL THE CHILD CAN
PROVIDE QUOTE UNQUOTE INFORMED
CONSENT. WHICH WE THOUGHT WAS
REASONABLE BECAUSE OUT OF WELL
DEVELOPED BODY OF CASE LAW BUT
VARIOUS SENATORS AND OTHERS
EXPRESSED- TO ME THAT- THAT
MIGHT BE A LITTLE TOO VAGUE
THAT A PHYSICIAN MAY NOT KNOW.
WHAT'S INFORMED CONSENT. SO WE
CHANGE IT TO MAKE IT A BRIGHT
LINE SIX YEARS OLD. AND THE
REASON THAT WE DID THAT WE
COULD'VE GONE OLDER DOESN'T
ARGUMENT TO SAY YOU CAN'T DO IT
TOOK KIDS EIGHTEEN. BUT WE MADE
IT SIX YEARS OLD WE THOUGHT IT
WOULD STRIKE A BALANCE THE KID
IS ABOUT TO START SCHOOL. FOR
THE STILL VERY EARLY IN THEIR
LIFE SO IF A SURGICAL DECISION
IS MADE- IT'S STILL THE KID IS
STILL VERY VERY. YOUNG BUT AT
SIX YEARS OLD A CHILD IS ABLE
TO SPEAK WITH THEIR PARENTS.
PARENTS ARE ABLE IN MAKING THE
PARENTAL DECISION TO SOLICIT
FEEDBACK FROM THE CHILD. WE
KNOW THAT A LOT OF KIDS WHO
WERE FOUR FIVE SIX ARE ALREADY
EXPRESSING WHAT THEIR GENDER.
IS BUT THAT'S MORE A MORE
COMMON THESE DAYS. IN ADDITION
KIDS CAN EXPRESS WHAT THEY WANT.
DO THEY WANT THEIR GENITALS TO
LOOK LIKE. THIS PERSON'S CHEN
SAID DADDY OR MOMMY OR OR THEIR
FRIENDS OR WHATEVER THEY CAN
EXPRESS A AND SO THE PARENT.
CAN MAKE THE DECISION AT LEAST
HAVING THAT LEVEL OF INPUT FROM
CHILD AND CAN DECIDE YOU KNOW
WHAT. THIS IS A LITTLE
CONFUSING LET'S WAIT A LITTLE
MORE LET'S DO IT- IN ADDITION
THE PARENT BECAUSE WE KNOW NOT
ALL PHYSICIANS. BUT THEREARE
SOME SITUATIONS WHERE PARENTS
THE CHILD IS BORN- AND THE AND
THE- GENERALS ARE A TYPICAL.
AND THEY HAVE NO IDEA WHAT JUST
HAPPENED AND WHAT'S GOING ON
THEY NEVER HEARD OF IT BEFORE
THEY DON'T KNOW. AND THAT A
PHYSICIAN WILL SAY. IN THIS
DOES HAPPEN. IF YOU DON'T DO
THE SURGERY YOUR KIDS GOING TO
BULLY THEIR LIFE IS GOING TO BE
MESSED UP. AND FOR PARENTS
PEOPLE YOU KNOW WE REVERE
DOCTORS AS WE SHOULD THESE ARE
PEOPLE WHO ARE SAVING LIVES.
AND FOR A LOT OF PEOPLE THEY
JUST GO WITH WHAT THE DOCTORS
RECOMMENDING THIS WILL GIVE
THEM A FEW YEARS. TO LOOK AT IT
EDUCATE THEMSELVES AND MAKE AN
INTEL GEN INFORMED DECISION. I
WANT TO ALSO NOTE. I HAVE
ENORMOUS RESPECT FOR THE
CALIFORNIA MEDICAL ASSOCIATION
AND FOR THIS- PROFESSION IN
GENERAL INCLUDING MY SISTER WHO
IS A POSITION IN NEW YORK. ON
AT AND THIS IS A PROFESSION
THAT SAVE LOTS SAVE LIVES EVERY
DAY IT'S A PROFESSION THAT I'M
USUALLY ALIGNED WITH AND IT'S
NOT COMFORTABLE. TO BE OFFICER-
THE- MEDICAL PROFESSION I'LL BE
VERY HONEST WITH YOU. BUT WE
NEED TO ALSO BE CLEAR THAT THE
MEDICAL PROFESSION IS VERY
DIVIDED ON THIS ISSUE AND THERE
ARE A LOT OF DOCTORS AND WE
HAVE ONE HERE TODAY INCLUDING
UROLOGISTS. WHO THINK THAT
THESE PROCEDURES SHOULD BE
BANNED- YOU HAVE A LETTER FROM
HUNDREDS OF PHYSICIANS IN
CALIFORNIA AND ELSEWHERE ASKING
YOU TO PASS THIS BILL. YOU HAVE
A LETTER- THAT IS SIGNED BY
THREE FORMER UNITED STATES
SURGEONS GENERAL. TO APPOINTED
BY BILL CLINTON WON BY GEORGE
W. BUSH. ALL AGREE NOT TO YOUR
POSITION ON THIS BILL BECAUSE
THE BUILDING EXIST WHEN THEY
SIGNED THE LETTER. BUT ALL
SAYING THAT THESE. PROCEDURES
SHOULD BE BANNED BUT THERE'S NO
REASON. TO HAVE THEM. ON THEY
SAID MAKE STATEMENTS LIKE WHEN
AN INDIVIDUAL IS BORN WITH A
TYPICAL GENITALIA WAS NO
PHYSICAL RISK. TREATMENT SHOULD
FOCUS NOT ON SURGICAL
INTERVENTION BUT ON
PSYCHOSOCIAL AND EDUCATIONAL
SUPPORT. BECAUSE MEDIC JANITOR
PLASTER SHOULD BE DEFERRED
UNTIL CHILDREN ARE OLD ENOUGH
TO VOICE THEIR OWN VIEW. ABOUT
WHETHER TO UNDERGO THE SURGERY.
AND FEDERAL PLEASE REVIEW YOU
KNOW YOU HAVE IT IN YOUR- IN
YOUR MATERIALS. ON THE UNITED
NATIONS AND ITS REPORT ON
TORTURE. STATES QUOTE CHILDREN
WHO WERE BORN WITH A TYPICAL
SEX CHARACTERISTICS ARE OFTEN
SUBJECT TO YOUR REVERSIBLE
SUCKS ASSIGNMENT INVOLUNTARY
STERILIZATION. INVOLUNTARY
JANET ON NORMALIZING SURGERY
PERFORMED WITHOUT THEIR
INFORMED CONSENT FOR THAT OF
THEIR PARENTS EVEN. AN ATTEMPT
TO QUOTE UNQUOTE FIX THEIR
SOCKS. LEAVING THEM WITH
PERMANENT YOUR REVERSIBLE AND
INFERTILITY AND CAUSING SEVERE
MENTAL SUFFERING. THE US STATE
DEPARTMENT SAYS QUOTE INTERSEX
PERSONS ROUTINELY FACE FORCE
MEDICAL SURGERIES. THAT ARE
CONDUCTED AT A YOUNG AGE
WITHOUT FREE OR INFORMED
CONSENT. PLEASE ENTER MENTIONS
JEOPARDIZE OUR PHYSICAL
INTEGRITY. AND ABILITY TO LIVE
FREE THESE ARE NOT FRIENDS
ORGANIZATIONS. THESE ARE
MAINSTREAM CREDIBLE
ORGANIZATIONS. AND THEN FINALLY
THERE'S BEEN A SUGGESTION THAT
WE'VE HEARD THAT CH CONGENITAL
ADRENAL HYPERPLASIA. SOMEHOW
NOT INNER SOCKS ON THE NATIONAL
INSTITUTES OF HEALTH WOULD
DISAGREE BECAUSE THEY DEFINE IT
AS- A CONDITION THAT LEADS TO
INTERSEX. TRAITS OF THE
SUGGESTION THAT CH AND ALSO HAD
THE SPEEDIEST. BE REMOVED FROM
THE BILL WHICH WOULD REMOVE THE
VAST MAJORITY OF INTERSEX
PEOPLE FROM THE BILL'S
PROTECTIONS. IT'S NOT
SOMETHING- THAT WE WOULD
SUPPORT A COLLEAGUES WE ARE IN
THE FIRST POLICY COMMITTEE. THE
VERY FIRST POLICY COMMITTEE AND
THE FIRST HOUSE ON AN IMPORTANT.
PRIORITY CIVIL RIGHTS BILL FOR
THE INNER. COMMUNITY AND FOR
THE LGBT COMMUNITY. I ASK YOU
TO MOVE THIS BILL OUT OF
COMMITTEE TODAY A SO THAT WE
CAN YOU TO WORK- AND DO THE
STAKEHOLDER OUTRAGE THAT WE
KNOW IS IMPORTANT- WITH ME HERE
TO TESTIFY. ON OR THE FOLLOWING
TWO WITNESSES WITH TWO OTHERS
WHO WILL BE AVAILABLE TO ANSWER
QUESTIONS WHEN THEY COME UP-
FIRST REX A BIRD THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF. QUALITY
CALIFORNIA- THAN BREA BROWN
CANYON INTERSEX PERSON AND
MEMBERSHIP COORDINATOR WITH THE
BOYS AND GIRLS CLUB OF DELAWARE
WHO FLEW OUT HERE FROM DELAWARE
TO TESTIFY BECAUSE THIS IS SO
IMPORTANT- AND THEN WE ALSO
HAVE WITH US DOCTOR BARBARA
CHIU BACK. AN ASSISTANT
PROFESSOR OF UROLOGY AT THE
ICAHN SCHOOL OF MEDICINE AT
MOUNT SINAI IN NEW YORK- WERE
MY SISTER THAT HER- THAT HER
UNDER- HER HER- RESIDENCY-
INCIDENTALLY- WHO ALSO FLEW OUT
HERE TO TESTIFY. ON FOR THIS
BILL. AND ALSO TO ANSWER
QUESTIONS PROFESSOR JULIE
GREENBERG- WHO IS THE AUTHOR OF
INTERSECTION WELL EDDIE AND THE
LAW SO THANK YOU FOR HEARING ME
OUT TODAY AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK YOUR AYE BILLS. THANK YOU
SENATOR WIENER. US WE INVITE
YOU TO WITNESSES TO US SPEAK. I
WOULD LIKE TO ASK THEM TO KEEP
THE REMARKS TO TWO MINUTES
TEACHERS WILL APPLY TO THE
OTHER SIDE AS WELL BOB THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE- REXBURG SECULAR
DIRECTOR OF A QUALITY
CALIFORNIA THE NATION'S LARGEST
STATEWIDE LGBT Q. CIVIL RIGHTS
ORGANIZATION AND A CO SPONSOR
OF SB TO A ONE. WE'RE PROUD TO
SUPPORT SB TWO A ONE BECAUSE AT
ITS CORE THIS BILL IS ABOUT THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA RESPECTING
INDIVIDUALS A TIME TO BE OVER
THEIR OWN BODY AND IN SOME
CASES GENDER IDENTITY WHICH IS
FUNDAMENTAL TO ALL OF OUR WORK
REGARDING LGBT Q. CIVIL RIGHTS.
THE ISSUE IS IN THE
INTERNATIONAL AND NATIONAL
SPOTLIGHT NOW THE U. N. HUMAN
RIGHTS COMMISSION THE EUROPEAN
PARLIAMENT HUMAN RIGHTS WATCH
THREE BIPARTISAN US SURGEON
GENERAL THE AMERICAN ACADEMY OF
FAMILY PHYSICIANS HAVE ALL
CALLED ON THE WORLD TO TAKE
ACTION AND PROTECT HUMAN RIGHTS
OF INTERSEX PEOPLE. IN JUST THE
LAST WEEK CNN PUBLISHED A SHORT
DOCUMENTARY HIGHLIGHTING THE
IMPORTANCE OF PROTECTING
CHILDREN BORN WITH SEX TRADE
VARIATIONS FROM THESE
INTERVENTIONS AND SPECIFICALLY
FOCUSED ON THIS BILL AND YOUR
VOTE TODAY. THE WORLD IS
LOOKING TO CALIFORNIA AND NEW
YORK SIMILAR BILLS BEING
CONSIDERED FOR LEADERSHIP ON
HUMAN RIGHTS. IT IS IMPORTANT
WE CONTINUE THAT LEADERSHIP
TODAY EVERY YEAR THOUSANDS OF
INTERSEX CHILDREN ARE BORN IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND
RIGHT NOW MEDICALLY ON
NECESSARY INVENTIONS CAUSAL
LASTING AND MINIMUM ARM ARE
FORMED ON GENDER OR THEY COULD.
SPEAK WHICH IS A CLEAR. RIGHTS
VIOLATION. I'M NOT A NURSE
PEOPLE ARE LGBT Q. MANY ARE.
MORE ISSUES OF SELF
DETERMINATION WITH RESPECT A
PERSON'S GENDER IDENTITY AND
EXPRESSION SEX AND SEXUAL
ORIENTATION OR ALL COURTS WERE%
MISSION AND ALLOWING
INSTITUTIONS OR OTHER PEOPLE.
TO DETERMINE THOSE MOST
PERSONAL ASPECTS OF OUR LIVES
IS AN EXACT IS IT IS AN
ACCIDENTAL STRESS STRESS.
STRESS THREATS TO LGBT Q. CIVIL
RIGHTS. WE'VE BEEN TOLD TIME
AND AGAIN. THAT IT'S NOT THE
LEGISLATURE'S ROLE TO TELL
PROFESSIONS WHAT THEY CAN AND
CANNOT DO BUT I REJECT THAT AND
IT CERTAINLY IS THE ROLE OF
THIS COMMITTEE. THOSE
CALIFORNIA LEGISLATURE
PROTECTED LGBTQ YOUTH FROM SO
CALLED CONVERSION THERAPY THE
CALIFORNIA LEGISLATURE
PROTECTED FEMALE INMATES FROM
FOR STERILIZATION. AND THE
CALIFORNIA LEGISLATURE HAS
PROTECTED MENTAL HEALTH
PATIENTS FROM ELECTRO SHOCK
THERAPY. IF WE CAN'T AGREE THAT
THE DEFENSE OF HUMAN RIGHTS IS
THE RESPONSIBILITY OF THE
CALIFORNIA LEGISLATURE THAN
RESPECTFULLY WHAT ARE WE ALL
DOING HERE. THE WORLD IS
WATCHING THE INTERSEX THE STILL
RIGHTS AND THE LGBT Q.
COMMUNITIES ARE WATCHING WILL
CALIFORNIA CONTINUE TO LEAD ON
HUMAN RIGHTS OR ARE WE GONNA
SEE THAT LEADERSHIP ROLE TO THE
YORK I RESPECTFULLY ADD. ASK
YOU FOR YOUR AYE BUT TODAY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH RICK NEXT
WITNESS. HI MY NAME IS BRIANNA
BROWN KING AND I WAS BORN WITH
CONGENITAL ADRENAL HYPERPLASIA
C. H. FOR SHORT. THIS MEANS
THAT MY BODY DOESN'T PRODUCE
ENOUGH CORTISOL A STRESS
HORMONE THAT OUR BODIES NEED TO
FUNCTION PROPERLY. AND TO
COMPENSATE MY BODY NATURALLY
PRODUCES HIGHER LEVELS OF
TESTOSTERONE. TESTOSTERONE
PRODUCES WHAT WE TYPICALLY
REFERRED TO AS SECONDARY MALE
CHARACTERISTICS I'M HERE TO
URGE YOU TO SUPPORT PEOPLE LIKE
ME BY PASSING SB TWO OH ONE AND
PROTECTING FUTURE INTERSECT
CHILDREN FROM THE PAIN AND
SUFFERING THAT I WENT THROUGH
AS A RESULT OF DEEPLY HARMFUL
SURGERY I UNDERWENT AS A CHILD.
CALIFORNIA SHOULD FOLLOW THE
LEAD OF GOVERNMENT AGENCIES
AGENCIES IN OTHER COUNTRIES
LIKE GERMANY SWITZERLAND
AUSTRALIA CHILE AND THE U.
EUROPEAN PARLIAMENT. AND
RESPECTED NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATIONS THAT FOCUS ON
PROTECTING CHILDREN. INCLUDING
THE UNITED NATIONS THE WORLD
HEALTH ORGANIZATION AMNESTY
INTERNATIONAL THE AMERICAN
ACADEMY OF FAMILY PHYSICIANS A
BIPARTISAN GROUP OF FORMER US
SURGEON GENERAL PHYSICIANS.
PHYSICIANS FOR HUMAN RIGHTS AND
THE HUMAN RIGHTS WATCH HUMAN
RIGHTS WATCH. AFTER STUDYING
THE ISSUE ALL OF THESE
GOVERNMENT AND NGO GROUPS
CONCLUDED THAT THESE MEDICALLY
UNNECESSARY SURGERIES SHOULD BE
PLUS POSTPONED UNTIL CHAU
CHILDREN ARE OLD ENOUGH TO BE
INVOLVED IN THE DECISION OF
WHETHER TO UNDERGO SURGERY. THE
SAN FRANCISCO HUMAN RIGHTS
COMMISSION ACTUALLY REACHED THE
SAME CONCLUSION FIFTEEN YEARS
AGO. PARENTS AND DOCTORS WANT
TO MAKE DECISIONS ABOUT
INTERSEX CHILDREN'S BODIES
BECAUSE THEY DEEM IT MEDICALLY
UNNECESSARY BASED ON THEIR FEAR
OF OUR HEALTHY BODIES. HOWEVER
WHAT THOSE INDIVIDUALS DON'T
WANT TO TALK ABOUT IS THAT WE
ARE PERFECT AS WE ARE. THEY
DON'T WANT TO TALK ABOUT THE
CASES LIKE MINE AND SO MANY
OTHERS WERE SURGERY DOESN'T GO
AS PLANNED. OR WHAT HAPPENS
YEARS LATER WHEN THEIR
DAUGHTERS REALIZE THAT THEY
CAN'T EXPERIENCE FOR SEXUAL
PLEASURE. BECAUSE THAT RIGHT
WAS STOLEN FROM THEM WITHOUT
THEIR CONSENT. OR KNOWLEDGE.
THE UROLOGIST TO PERFORM MY
SURGERY A SHORT MY FAMILY IN
THE UNDER GORING UNDERGOING A
VAGINAL CLASS THE TO MAKE MY
GENITALS APPEAR MORE NORMAL.
WOULD ENABLE ME TO BE ABLE TO
USE MY **** I DON'T KNOW WHY HE
SEEMED TO KNOW ABOUT HOW I
WOULD OR WOULD NOT WANT TO USE
MY **** WHY ARE DOCTORS MORE
CONCERNED ABOUT PREPARING US TO
HAVE SEX. WITH THEIR HUSBANDS
AND ACTUALLY HAVING A HEALTHY
BODY CAPABLE OF SEXUAL PLEASURE.
THESE HIGH RISK IN A REVERSIBLE
SURGERIES ARE PERFORMED TO.
CONFIRM OUR BODIES TO GENDER
EXPECTATIONS OFTEN WITHOUT
PATIENTS HAVING LITTLE OR NO
SAY IN THIS PERSONAL DECISION.
TO DETERMINE WHAT IF ANY
TREATMENT OR SURGERY IS
APPROPRIATE FOR US. THEY MAY
WELL THEY MAY BE WELL
INTENTIONED BUT THE SURGERIES
ARE OFTEN CARRIED OUT WITH THE
ASSUMPTION THAT THIS IS WHAT
THE CHILDREN WHAT ONE AS
ADULTS. IN MY CASE I NEVER DID
USE MY **** IN THE WAY THAT THE
DOCTOR SOON I WOULD BECAUSE
MOST OF MY INTIMATE PARTNERS
HAVE BEEN CISGENDER WOMEN.
INSTEAD OF PREPARE ME FOR ****
MY UROLOGIST COULD HAVE.
AFFIRMED THAT THAT THERE WAS
NOTHING WRONG WITH MY INTERSECT
BODY. I STARTED TO PERSONALLY
IDENTIFIES INTERSECTS BEFORE I
EVEN KNEW WHAT THE TERM WAS. I
KNEW THAT I WAS DIFFERENT EVEN
THOUGH MY FAMILY AND MY DOCTORS
TRIED TO TRIED HARD TO CONVINCE
ME OTHERWISE. EVENTUALLY I
REALIZED THAT I WASN'T JUST A
NORMAL GIRL. THAT EVERYONE IN
MY LIFE WHEN IT NEEDS TO BE. C.
H. MANIFEST ITSELF DIFFERENTLY
FOR EVERYONE. IT IS IMPORTANT
FOR YOUNG INTERSEXUAL DURING.
TO GO THROUGH THE NATURAL
STAGES OF HUMAN AND CHARACTER
DEVELOPMENT BEFORE MAKING A
DECISION THAT COULD IMPACT
THEIR LIVES FOR EVER. BECAUSE
SOMETIMES CAN DOCTORS DO YOU
GET IT WRONG. I AM THE CHILD OF
A MOTHER WHO TRULY THOUGHT SHE
WAS DOING WHAT WAS BEST FOR ME.
BUT GOT IT WRONG. I HONESTLY
WOULD HAVE KEPT MY LARGE ****
HAD I KNOWN THEN WHAT I KNOW
NOW. WHEN IT COMES TO NON
NECESSARY MEDICAL PROCEDURES
CHILDREN DESERVE. TO BE OLD
ENOUGH TO MAKE INFORMED
DECISIONS ABOUT THEIR BODIES. I
AM SO GRATEFUL TO CENTER WIENER
FOR INTRODUCING A BILL THAT
WOULD HELP PRESERVE OPTIONS FOR
PEOPLE LIKE ME. AND DELAY
MEDICALLY UNNECESSARY SURGERIES
UNTIL PATIENTS CAN'T
PARTICIPATE IN THESE DECISIONS
AND DETERMINE WHAT TREATMENT OR
SURGERY IS RIGHT FOR THEM.
CHILDREN BORN IN CALIFORNIA
DESERVE TO BE PROTECTED AGAINST
INJUSTICE AND NO ONE SHOULD
EVER HAVE TO SEE JUSTICE
JUSTICE FOR THE RIGHT WAY FOR
THEIR OWN BODY. IT'S TIME TO
SEND CENTER CARE ON THE NEEDS
OF PATIENTS THEMSELVES THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. TO
YOU BREA AND TO WRECK- WE'D
LIKE TO INVITE THOSE WHO SHARE
THAT VIEW TO PLEASE COME UP TO
THE MICROPHONE AND IDENTIFY
YOURSELF AND DO A ME TOO. CAN
BE MARTIN ON BEHALF OF EQUALITY
CALIFORNIA OF COURSE A PROUD CO
SPONSOR OF THIS BILL ALSO
STATING THE SUPPORT OF TO OUR
PARTNER ORGANIZATIONS WHO COULD
NOT BE HERE TODAY. THE
TRANSLATING A COALITION AND THE
CALIFORNIA LGBT Q. HEALTH AND
HUMAN SERVICES NETWORK THINKING
THANK YOU. ASSOCIATED STUDENTS
OF UC DAVIS FOR SUPPORT FOR
THIS BILL THANK YOU. I ALSO
LISTED AT UC DAVIS SUPPORTING
THE STUFF THANK YOU. HANS LE
DAHLE INTERSEX CALIFORNIAN AND
COMMUNICATIONS DIRECTOR FOR
INTERACTIVE FROM SUPPORT THANK
YOU. HI ISRAELI OF CALIFORNIA
ALSO PROUD CO SPONSOR OF THIS
BILL URGE SUPPORT THANK YOU.
OLEANDER QUADRA COMMUNITY
MEMBERS STRONG SUPPORTER OF SB
TWO OH ONE Q. NOVA QUADRA
STRONG SUPPORTER PRESS BE TWO
OH ONE THANK YOU. FILL IN
VERSION STAFF ATTORNEY AND
INTERACT PROUD COSPONSOR A
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK
YOU. HI AM EVAN MAINTAIN I'M
HERE AS AN OF REPRESENTATIVE OF
VOICES FOR PROGRESS AS A
REPRESENTATIVE OF THE
CALIFORNIA DEMOCRATIC PARTY
LGBT CAUCUS AND ALSO IS A
PROUD. TRANSGENDER INDIVIDUAL
URGING YOUR SUPPORT FOR THIS
IMPORTANT BILL AND APPLAUDING
SENATOR WIENER FOR CONTINUING
THIS FIGHT. THANK YOU. MY
NAME'S MUDDY ROBY I'M INTERSEX
PERSON WITH INTERACT- THE
GENDER WHOLE CENTER AND THE
SACRAMENTO LGBT COMMUNITY
CENTER AS PART. THANK YOU. KICK
A TAURUS I COMMUNICATIONS
MANAGER FOR THE GENERAL TENOR
IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU. I
HAVE A LOWER GRADE ARTIST
WRITER MEMBER OF THE LGBT Q. A
COMMUNITY IN RESIDENT OF SAN
FRANCISCO STRUCK SUPPORT. MY
NAME IS SON DOUBLE CASITAS OF I
AM SUPPORT OF THIS BILL AND I'M
A COMMITTEE MEMBER THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. MY NAME IS CAITLYN
LOPEZ AND I'M IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF THIS BILL. I GET KATE'S
COMMUNITY MEMBER IN STRONG
SUPPORT. JERRY TROY COMMUNITY
MEMBER STRONG SUPPORTER OF THIS
BILL. JEFFREY IS REPRESENTING
MYSELF A STRONG SUPPORTER AND A
BOARD MEMBER CALL CALIFORNIA
ALBUM IMPORTANT THIS BILL IS TO
US THANK YOU THANK YOU. AB
NOMINATION I AM- SACRAMENTO
RESIDENT AT SAKS CITY COLLEGE
AND ALSO SUPPORT THIS BILL
THANK YOU VERY GOOD ANYBODY
ELSE WANT TO COME AND IDENTIFY
THEMSELVES IN FAVOR THE BILL
PLEASE COME ON UP. ALL RIGHT
WITH THAT WE'RE GONNA. INVITE
THOSE IN OPPOSITION TO- TO COME
AND SHARE THEIR VIEWS IF YOU
CAN CLEAR A LITTLE BIT OF SPACE
THE TABLE OUT OF THEM WE MAY
HAVE. WELCOME BACK ABOUT. OKAY.
SO TO THE TO THE OPPONENTS ARE
WE DID ALLOW THE SUPPORTERS TO
GO OVER- WE HAD ALLOCATED FOR
MINUTES- TO THEM AND THEY WENT
TO SEVEN AND A HALF MINUTES SO
WE'RE GONNA TRY TO. HAVE EQUAL
TIME HERE AND- MAKE SURE YOU
UNDERSTAND THAT YOU CAN. GIVE
US INSIGHT Là AGENT BUT IN
SEVEN ADMINISTER LOTS OF
WELCOME. THANK YOU. GOOD
AFTERNOON THANK YOU FOR THIS
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OF SB TO A ONE MY
NAME IS HILARY COP I AM A
CALIFORNIAN I WAS BORN AND
RAISED HERE. I'M LGBT. I AM A
PEDIATRIC UROLOGIST THAT YOU
SEE SAN FRANCISCO. MY DIVISION
OF PEDIATRIC NEUROLOGY IS ONE
THAT SPECIALIZES IN TREATING
CHILDREN WITH DIFFERENCES IN
SEX DEVELOPMENT ALSO KNOWN AS
DST. I CHOSE A CAREER IN
MEDICINE BECAUSE I'M PASSIONATE
ABOUT HELPING PEOPLE LEAD
HEALTHIER AND HAPPIER LIVES.
AND I TAKE GREAT PRIDE IN OUR
WORK. MUCH OF WHICH ENTAILS
ADVOCATING FOR OUR PATIENTS
INDIVIDUAL NEEDS. THIS INCLUDES
MAKING INDIVIDUALIZED
RECOMMENDATIONS FOR EACH
PATIENT BY EDUCATING FAMILIES
SO THEY CAN ACT IN THEIR
CHILD'S BEST INTEREST. I FIRMLY
BELIEVE THAT HEALTH CARE IS NOT
A ONE SIZE FITS ALL. SB TWO OH
ONE HOWEVER TREATS EVERY CHILD
THE SAME IGNORING THE POTENTIAL
IMPACT OF DELAYED TREATMENT.
SENATE BILL TWO OH ONE
PROHIBITS ANY MEDICAL TREATMENT
FOR ALL CHILDREN BORN WITH
VARIATIONS IN SEX
CHARACTERISTICS UNTIL THE AGE
OF SIX. IT'S IMPORTANT YOU KNOW
THAT THIS BILL DOESN'T JUST
IMPACT THE FEW RARE INTERSECTS
CASES. BUT INSTEAD TREATS
ROUTINE AND COMPLEX CASES
EQUALLY. IN DOING SO THE BILL
REMOVES ALL FLEXIBILITY FOR
TRAINED MEDICAL PROFESSIONALS
AND THEIR LOVED ONES TO DO WAS
IN THE BEST INTEREST OF THE
PATIENT. THE BILL DOES PROVIDE
A PATH FOR TREATMENT DEEMED
MEDICALLY NECESSARY THE BILL
CHARGES THE MEDICAL BOARD IN
CONJUNCTION WITH A DEFINED
COMMITTEE OF TEN TO DETERMINE
WHAT IS AND WHAT ISN'T
MEDICALLY NECESSARY FOR ROUTINE
AND COMPLEX CASES. THIS IS A
DANGEROUS PRECEDENT THAT PLACE
IS THE TREATMENT OF CHILDREN IN
THE HANDS OF A FEW. THEY CANNOT
TAKE INTO ACCOUNT EACH PATIENT
SPECIFIC SET OF CIRCUMSTANCES
ABOUT WHICH THEY ARE MAKING A
DECISION. AN ODDLY ONLY A FEW
OF THE INDIVIDUALS DETERMINING
MEDICAL CARE OR EVEN REQUIRED
TO BE PHYSICIANS LET ALONE
SPECIALISTS WHO CARE FOR THESE
CHILDREN. TREATMENT OF DST HAS
ADVANCED SIGNIFICANTLY IN THE
LAST TWENTY YEARS IT'S
UNFORTUNATE THAT MANY
SUPPORTERS OF THIS BILL SITE
CASES FROM OVER THIRTY YEARS
AGO AS JUSTIFICATION TO PASS
THIS BILL. OUR SPECIALTY AND
THE LARGER MEDICAL COMMUNITY
CONTINUE TO REVIEW AND STUDY
THESE COMPLEX CONDITIONS IN
ORDER TO ADVANCE THE CARE FOR
PATIENTS THAT WE ARE DISCUSSING
TODAY. WE NOW HAVE A RIGOROUS
TEAM BASED APPROACH INVOLVING
MULTI MULTIPLE SPECIALTIES TO
PROVIDE FAMILIES WITH RESOURCES
AND IMPORTANTLY CHOICES.
SURGERY IS NOT ALWAYS
RECOMMENDED IT IS IMPORTANT TO
HAVE OPTIONS AND DIFFICULT AND
COMPLEX SITUATIONS AND
CIRCUMSTANCES SB- ONE REMOVES
THIS SB TWO OH ONE REMOVES THIS.
WHILE I UNDERSTAND THE SENATORS
CAN INTENT I AM CONCERNED THAT
WITHHOLDING TREATMENT OPTIONS
FOR COMPLEX MEDICAL CASES WILL
NEGATIVELY IMPACT THE CHILDREN
THAT ARE AFFECTED BY THIS BILL.
SENATE BILL TWO OH ONE IS THE
WRONG APPROACH AND WE
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOU TO VOTE NO.
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THE NEXT WITNESS. GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS KAREN
BOGARD I'M A LIFELONG
CALIFORNIA RESIDENT A BOARD
MEMBER AND IMMEDIATE PAST BOARD
CHAIR OF CARES FOUNDATION AND
MOTHER OF A SON WHO HAS SOUGHT
WASTING CAN GENERAL ADRENAL
HYPERPLASIA RCH. AT THE TIME
OUR THIRD SON WAS BORN WE KNEW
SOMETHING WASN'T RIGHT HE WAS
VOMITING LOSING WEIGHT AND
BECOMING MORE LETHARGIC BUT WE
HAD NO IDEA HE HAD C. H. UNTIL
HE NEARLY DIED OF AN ADRENAL
CRISIS AT THREE WEEKS OF AGE.
THAT EXPERIENCE WAS NOT UNUSUAL
AT THE TIME FORTUNATELY THAT'S
NOW RARE IN THE U. S. BECAUSE
OF THE EFFORTS OF CARES
FOUNDATION WHO SUCCESSFULLY
ADVOCATED FOR CH NEWBORN
SCREENING. IN ALL FIFTY STATES
C. H. IS A LIFE THREATENING
MEDICAL CONDITION THAT AFFECTS
BOTH MALES AND FEMALES. BUT
CERTAINLY DOES NOT IMPACT EACH
PATIENT EQUALLY THEIR VARIOUS
FORMS OF C. H. SOME OF WHICH
CAN LEAD TO VARIATIONS IN
SEXUAL CHARACTERISTICS. THE
PATIENTS HOWEVER ARE
GENETICALLY MALE OR FEMALE AND
THE VAST MAJORITY DO NOT
IDENTIFY AS INTERSEX. THIS BILL
HAS CONSISTENTLY INCLUDED CH
WITHIN ITS DEFINITION EVEN
AFTER THE MAJORITY OF THE C. H.
COMMUNITY HAS REPEATEDLY ASKED
FOR IT TO BE REMOVED. THE VAST
MAJORITY OF PATIENTS WITH CH DO
NOT SUPPORT THIS BILL AND
OPPOSE A ONE SIZE FITS ALL
APPROACH TO CARING FOR THOSE
WITH THIS COMPLICATED MEDICAL
CONDITION. IT'S TROUBLING TO C.
H. FAMILIES WHO HAVE A HIGHER
LIKELIHOOD OF HAVING ANOTHER
CHILD WITH C. H. TO THINK THAT
THIS BILL COULD RESTRICT ANY
TREATMENT UNTIL THE ARBITRARY
AGE OF SIX. AND JUSTICE
TROUBLING TO FOR ALL MEDICALLY
NECESSARY QUESTIONS TO A GROUP
OF PEOPLE WHO HAVE NEVER SEEN
OR TREATED THEIR CHILD. HERE'S
FOUNDATION AND I ARE NOT
ADVOCATES FOR SURGERY OR
MANDATING ANY PARTICULAR
TREATMENT. WE BELIEVE FAMILY
SHOULD BE AFFORDED THE
OPPORTUNITY TO CARE FOR THEIR
CHILDREN WITH ALL AVAILABLE
TREATMENT OPTIONS AND WITHOUT
THE HARSH RESTRICTIONS IN
SENATE BILL TO A ONE. BECAUSE
OF MY BOARD INVOLVEMENT I KNOW
FULL WELL HOW DIFFICULT IT IS
FOR WOMEN WHO ARE SATISFIED
WITH THEIR TREATMENT AT AN
EARLY AGE TO COME FORWARD. AND
SHARE SUCH PERSONAL MEDICAL
STORIES IN A PUBLIC FORUM. IT'S
IMPORTANT THEY HAVE A VOICE.
GIRLS WITH CH ARE
DISPROPORTIONATELY THE LARGEST
GROUP AFFECTED BY THIS BILL. AS
A GROUP THEY OVERWHELMINGLY
OPPOSE SB TO A ONE. ON BEHALF
OF CH PATIENTS AND FAMILIES
THROUGHOUT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA I URGE YOU TO VOTE
NO ON SB TWO OH ONE THANK YOU.
VERY GOOD THANK YOU VERY MUCH-
AS BOGART AND THANK YOU DOCTOR
COP FOR YOUR TESTIMONY I'D LIKE
TO INVITE. OTHERS WHO WERE IN
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL TO COME
UP TO THE MICROPHONE AND- AND
DO A ME TOO ON- WITH YOUR NAME
AND YOUR AFFILIATION IF ANY.
GOOD AFTERNOON MATT BACK
REPRESENT A SOCIETY OF
PEDIATRIC UROLOGY AND THE
OSTEOPATHIC PHYSICIANS AND
SURGEONS OF CALIFORNIA IN
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL. THANK
YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON- MISTER
MEMBERS BRANDON MARCH WITH THE
CALIFORNIA MEDICAL ASSOCIATION
ALSO IN OPPOSITION. THANK YOU.
HELLO SCOTT SPARKS PEDIATRIC
UROLOGIST AT CHILDREN'S
HOSPITAL LOS ANGELES AND MEMBER
OF THE LGBT COMMUNITY STRONGLY
OPPOSED TO THIS BILL. HELLO HI
MY NAME'S RANDY OLSON I'M A
GRANDFATHER OF A GIRL HAS
CLASSIC CH AND I AM OPPOSE.
HELLO MY NAME'S COURTNEY BAKER
AND THE MOTHER OF A CHILD
CLASSICS THE AGE AND I AM
OPPOSED. THANK YOU. HELLO I'M
GENERALLY CORA AND I'M THE
MOTHER OF A CHILD WITH
CLASSICAL CH AND I'M OPPOSED.
MY NAME IS LILY WOMAN PEDIATRIC
UROLOGIST A VALLEY CHILDREN'S
HOSPITAL MADERA I STRONGLY
OPPOSE. DEMAND REPRESENT THE
CALIFORNIA SOCIETY OF PLASTIC
SURGEONS IN OPPOSITION. RENTS
SPENCER WITH AMERICAN COLLEGE
OBGYN STRYCHNINE OPPOSITION.
AARON TAYLOR WITH THE CHILDREN
SPECIALTY CARE COALITION AND
RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION. I MEAN I
MEAN CHAO I'M A GET YOUR
LAGEST OF THE MIND THE
INDUCTION AS HOSPITAL UP WAS
HIS BILL. RICHARD MOGENSEN I'M
A PROFESSOR AT UC MEDICAL
CENTER. I WANT YOU TO. CLOSELY
LOOK AT SECTION E. DASH ONE OF
NINE THINGS THAT INTERFERE.
WITH TREATING PEOPLE UNDER SIX
YEARS OF AGE. TRICIA BARRETT I
HAVE A FAMILY MEMBER WITH C. H.
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSED TO SPELL.
AMERICA O'GARA TRAVELED FROM
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA WHERE IT
WAS BORN AND RAISED I HAVE
SOLELY SEEN CH AND I DO NOT SEE
IT AS AN ERROR SEX CONDITION.
MY NAME IS JANET I TRAVELED UP
FROM SAN DIEGO. I WAS BORN WITH
CH.HAD BY SUCCESSFUL SURGERY
AT AGE TWELVE. A AND WE SHOULD
HAVE BEEN AS AN INFANT I A IS
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK
YOU VERY MUCH OTHER. ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION THAT
WOULD WANT TO COME TO THE
MICROPHONE. OKAY SO WE'RE GONNA
CLOSE THA A PART OF OUR PUBLIC
HEARING AT INVITES. MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE TO ASK ANY
QUESTIONS THAT THEY WOULD LIKE
TO ASK. THE QUESTIONS. OKAY.
NOT I WILL GO AHEAD DOCTOR
SENATOR PAT. I THANK YOU SO
VERY MUCH AND I. FIRST OF ALL I
WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR- FOR
THE CONVERSATION AND YOU KNOW I
DID VOTE FOR THE RECALL
RESOLUTION. I AM CONCERNED
BECAUSE THAT IN TERMS OF. THIS.
THEY'RE ALL AND WE'RE NOW
SAYING THAT IT'S UNPROFESSIONAL
BEHAVIOR PERFORM ANY SORT OF
MEDICAL TREATMENT- NOW THIS HE
SAID MEDICALLY UNNECESSARY AND
I THINK THAT'S THE RUB EXACTLY
HOW WE DEFINE SO PERHAPS AND I
KNOW THAT THE WITNESS IN
OPPOSITION- AND- STRENGTH LIKE
IN YOUR NAME RIGHT NOW DR.
HILLARY COP OKAY BACK DOCTOR
COP- CAN YOU DESCRIBE HE'S
TALKED ABOUT MULTI THIS MAY
PROCESS CAN YOU DESCRIBE WHAT
THE CURRENT. STATE OF THE ART
IS THE CURRENT PROCESS YOUR
UCSF- WHEN A CHILD IS BORN WITH
L. INTERSECTION ASIAN YOU'RE
RIGHT IT'S NOT ABOUT
CHROMOSOMES IT'S- SO YOU HAVE A
CHILD WHO HAS I GUESS WE CALL A
TYPICAL IS RIGHT WORD- BUT-
GENITALIA WHAT WHAT IS THE
PROCESS BY WHICH- YOU EVALUATE
THAT PATIENT. AND HOW ARE
DECISIONS MADE ABOUT WHICH
TREATMENTS INCLUDING
PROCEDURES. SHOULD BE DONE MORE
URGENTLY AND WHICH ONES. CAN
CAN WAIT. AT THAT BECAUSE I
THINK THAT'S- I THINK THERE'S A
GOOD CASE TO SAY THAT WELL
WHAT'S THE RUSH RIGHT OUT FOR
MANY OF THESE THINGS. SO HOW
HOW'S THAT. CURRENTLY DONE- NOW
SO IF YOU HAD A PATIENT WHO WAS
BORN- AND DAY CONSULT YOU NOW
AND THAT THAT THAT THAT COULD
HAPPEN TOMORROW A PIE HAPPENED
LAST WEEK WHAT WE PUT TO TELL
ME WHAT HAPPENS. ABSOLUTELY AND
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TO DISCUSS THIS MORE. YOU'RE
VERY CORRECT ON THIS ISN'T
SOMETHING WHERE WE JUST LOOK AT
IT AND SAY THIS PATIENT LOOKS
LIKE A BOY OR A GIRL AND DECIDE
ON SURGICAL INTERVENTIONS IN
FACT- WE THIS IS ABOUT CHOICE.
THIS IS. A VERY COMPLEX PROCESS
AND- DECISION- DECISIONS THAT
ARE MADE. THE MULTI MULTI
DISCIPLINARY TEAM INVOLVES-
PHYSICIANS- FROM VARIOUS
SPECIALTIES INCLUDING PEDIATRIC
ENDOCRINOLOGY PEDIATRIC
NEUROLOGY PSYCHIATRY GENETICS.
THIS ISN'T JUST ABOUT THE
CHROMOSOMES BUT IT IS ALSO
ABOUT THE CHROMOSOMES ABOUT THE
GONADS IT'S ABOUT THE- PHYSICAL
APPEARANCE ALL OF THOSE THINGS
TOGETHER. BUT WE SPEND ENORMOUS
AMOUNTS OF TIME AND OF SPENT
YEARS STUDYING THIS AND IT IS
AN EXTREMELY COMPLEX PROCESS
THAT WE HAVE A SIGNIFICANT
AMOUNT OF CONCERN. WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT TEN PEOPLE THREE
OF WHICH- OUR PHYSICIANS THAT
MOST LIKELY ARE NOT FROM THE
SPECIFIC SPECIALTIES THAT HAVE
SPENT ALL THIS TIME STUDYING
THESE CONDITIONS AND CONTINUING
TO STUDY THEM. THE BABY IS
BORN- THERE IS NOTHING
IMMEDIATELY DONE FOR THE BABY
OTHER THAN MEDICAL TREATMENTS
THAT ARE EXTREMELY IMPORTANT
ESPECIALLY IN SITUATIONS SUCH
AS SALT WASTING CH. OF THE BABY
WERE SENT HOME AND THIS WAS NOT
IDENTIFIED IN MEDICAL
TREATMENTS WERE GIVEN THE BABY
WOULD WOULD DIE FROM A CRISIS
AT HOME. THEY CAN GET
INFECTIONS AND DIE FROM
OVERWHELMING STRESS AT THIS
CAUSES IN THE BODY. THERE ARE
ABSOLUTELY NO IMMEDIATE-
DECISIONS MADE AND THERE ARE
MULTIPLE VISITS IN MULTIPLE
CONVERSATIONS WITH FAMILY
MEMBERS WITH MULTIPLE
PHYSICIANS OF ALL SPECIAL. ON
A- US. THREE AND IN FACT. VERY
RARELY ARE WE ACTUALLY TALKING
ABOUT SURGERY THAT IS JUST AN
OPTION AND IF WE EXCLUDE THESE
OPTIONS WILL HAVE PATIENTS NOT
WALKING INTO OUR DOORS AND IN
FACT. GOING ELSEWHERE IN IN IN
IT WILL BE THAT PEOPLE WITH
LESS MEANS THAT ARE UNABLE TO
TRAVEL TO OTHER PLACES TO HAVE-
THESE DISCUSSIONS THAT WILL IN
FACT SUFFER BUT THE PEOPLE WHO
STILL WANT SURGERY AND KNOW
THAT IT'S THERE ARE GOING TO GO
ELSEWHERE. FOR US THIS IS NOT
ABOUT SURGERY WE DON'T WE'RE
NOT HERE FOR SURGERY OR AGAINST
SURGERY AND THAT'S EXTREMELY
IMPORTANT AND WE'RE NOT.
PERFORMING THE SURGERIES. THAT
ARE BEING INSINUATED- WE ARE
OFFERING. ALL MEDICAL TREATMENT
OPTIONS AND IN FACT WHEN WE ARE
UNSURE OF DIAGNOSES THE
MAJORITY OF THE TIME AND
CLINICS SUCH AS THIS THAT ARE
AT. MULTI THAT MULTI DISCIPLINE
CONNECTS OUR AT OUR AT ACADEMIC
CENTERS WHEN WE ARE ENSURE WE
ARE WE ARE NOT OFFERING
SURGERY. IT'S IT WE ARE
DISCUSSING SURGERY AND THAT IS
AND WE'RE NOT PUSHING IT IT'S
AN OPTION OKAY SIDE OF AYE
CLARIFIED BECAUSE WHEN. ONE OF
THE CONTENTIONS WAS IS THAT.
PHYSICIANS ARE PUSHING ACT BE
PUSHING PERRANCE THING THAT YOU
NEED TO HAVE SURGERY TO FIX
THIS YOU'RE SAYING THAT. I MEAN
WE'RE NOT TALKING ABOUT THIRTY
YEARS AGO AND I'VE YOU KNOW IS
WHAT. I'M TALKING ABOUT BECAUSE
THIS LAWS ABOUT NOW AND INTO
THE FUTURE RIGHT AND ONE. YEAH
ONE OF THE- MOST IMPORTANT
THINGS ABOUT BEING A SURGEON IS
NEVER PUSHING AN AGENDA OR A
SURGERY THAT'S NOT THAT'S NOT
HOW WE- THAT'S NOT HOW WE
OPERATE IT'S AND IT'S IMPORTANT
TO MAKE SURE. THAT THAT THE
DECISION IS MADE AND IT'S AN
INFORMED DECISION THAT'S MADE
TOGETHER THERE'S SHARED
DECISION MAKING THAT OCCURS
WITH THE FAMILY. AND KNOW WHERE
WE ARE PUSHING ANY AGENDA IT'S
ABOUT OPTIONS AND EDUCATION-
AND ANY THEN YOU JUST CLARIFY-
SO ONE OF THE SITUATIONS THAT I
THINK THE PROPONENTS HAVE
EXPRESSED CONCERN I THINK
REASONABLE CONCERN IS THAT OKAY.
CHILD BORN PARENT. ANXIOUS
RIGHT BECAUSE YOU ASKED OAK
HILL THAT THAT MIGHT MY ANSWER
TO PEOPLE AS KIDS LIKE LET'S
WRAP OR SCORE THE MOST USED AS
BOY OR GIRL RIGHT. AND THEN
THEY GET AND- THEY WANT TO BE
ABLE TO GET AN ANSWER AND SOON
CERTAIN PARENTS THE ONLY
DEPENDING ON THEIR BACKGROUND-
ARE- SO FORTH MAY WANT TO. PUSH
FOR SURGERY TO RESOLVE THAT
QUESTION HAVE YOU AND YOUR PS
CRAWLERS HAVE YOU EVER TOLD.
NOT MAYBE IT'S BEST TO WAIT WE
THAT'S NOT SOMETHING THAT NEEDS
TO BE RESOLVED RIGHT NOW I MEAN
IT DO YOU ACTUALLY DISCOURAGE
SURGERY WHEN YOU FEEL THAT IT'S
AN APPROPRIATE FOR THE CHILD
ABSOLUTELY ABSOLUTELY AND IN
FACT WE DON'T EVEN ASSIGNED
GENDERS WHEN WORKERS. WE TALK
ABOUT THE BABY. TALK ABOUT FOR
RIGHT NOW IT'S SO MUCH HARDER
TO ASSIGN A GENDER AND COME
BACK WITH OUR OF SO MANY
THINGS. THAT WEREN'T SURE ABOUT
THIS SUCH A COMPLEX ISSUE. AND
OF COURSE WE WANT RIGHT THERE
WE NEVER WANT TO DO ANYTHING WE
FULLY ARMY. ANY ANY. THERE IS A
SIGNED AND REFERRING TO THE TO
THE CHILD AS THE BABY. AND THEN
THAT FURTHER TESTING WILL NEED
TO HAPPEN INCLUDING A GENETIC
TESTING HORMONAL TESTING AND
THEN WE HAVE A VERY SUPPORTIVE
ENVIRONMENT WE CAN LEARN MORE
ABOUT THIS WE DO A LINE THEM
WITH- ORGANIZATIONS WITH THEY
CAN TALK TO OTHER FAMILIES ARE
ALSO GOING THROUGH THESE
THINGS. OKAY AND THEN FINALLY.
SO SOMEONE MIGHT SAY OKAY WELL
YOU KNOW THIS IF THAT'S WHAT
YOU DO THIS BILL DOESN'T. DO
ANYTHING STOP YOU FROM DOING
THAT SO WHAT'S THE PROBLEM WITH
THIS BILL SO WHAT WHAT IS IT
WHAT WOULD THIS BILL IT BECAME
LAW STOP YOU FROM DOING THAT
MIGHT BE HARMFUL TO THE CHILD.
WELL FIRST OF ALL AGAIN. I
THINK IT TAKES AWAY THE ABILITY
TO HAVE CONVERSATIONS ABOUT
THINGS AND PERCENT OPTIONS. IN
INFORMED THAT THE FAMILY
MEMBERS. IT ALSO IS VERY BROAD
AND IN IN OUR OPINION IS GOES
WELL BEYOND WHAT WE KNOW. TO
MEAN INTERSEX AND WE WILL
CERTAINLY SAY THAT THIS IS A
THIS IS OF A VERY QUIET COMPLEX
CONDITION OF MANY CONDITIONS
THAT THE POTENTIALLY CAN- MAKE
UP THE DEFINITION OF INTERSEX
AND THAT'S WHAT WE SEE SUCH
VARIATIONS IN THE INCIDENCE OF
INTERNET INTERSEX WILL. WILL
HEAR OF ANYWHERE FROM. 1% TWO
VERSES ONE AND A FORTY FIVE
HUNDRED WHICH WOULD BE MORE-
REALISTIC AND HOW WE VIEW
INTERSECTS BUT CERTAINLY. TO AS
YOU HEARD EARLIER THERE ARE BY
MANY PEOPLE- WITH A CH THE DO
NOT FEEL THAT INTERSEX- IS AT
THAT CH IS AN INTERSEX
CONDITION AND IN FACT THERE ARE
STUDIES THAT SUPPORT THAT 95%
OF- OF FIVE C. H. PATIENTS THAT
ARE- RAISED AS FEMALE IDENTIFY
AS FEMALE AND A FEW PRCENT.
HAVE A GENDER ISSUES- ABOUT ONE
PERCENT- AND THAT'S A
DOCUMENTED STUDY ACTUALLY IN
THE REPORT FOR TWO THOUSAND AND
FIVE- BYE DESTINED IN
COLLEAGUES. AND ALSO-
HYPOSPADIAS HYPOSPADIAS IS IN
AND OF ITSELF A VERY COMPLEX
ISSUE YES SOMETIMES IT IS
ASSOCIATED WITH INTERSEX BUT-
ABOVE AND BY FAR. THE MAJORITY
OF HYPE IS BADIUS THAT WE SEE
AND TREAT I IS NOT A PART OF AN
INNER SIX CONDITION AND I
THINK. TO LIMIT US IN AND BUY A
BROADLY SAYING AND INCLUDING
THOSE THOSE SAID BOTH CH
HYPOSPADIAS OR EVEN TRYING TO.
NAIL DOWN SPECIFIC DIAGNOSES
YOU CAN SEE THERE'S ALREADY
CONFUSION AND THAT AND SO I
HAVE EXTREME- CONCERNED THAT IF
WE LEGISLATE THIS ISSUE THAT
THERE ARE TO BE A GENERATION OF
CHILDREN. WHOSE PURPOSE ON
CONSEQUENCES. BUT WE ARE. OKAY
SO- I'VE KATE. BY YOUR
RESPONSES TO THE QUESTIONS-
NIGHT. I THANK THE BROADNESS IS
A BIT CONCERNING I. AGAIN AN
EXAMPLE THAT AND FOR CHAD
PERSONAL EXPERIENCE WITH THAT
IS THAT WE A CHILD WHO IS BORN-
THE PARENTS REQUESTED A
CIRCUMCISION I KNOW THERE'S
PEOPLE OUT THERE WHO MIGHT FEEL
CIRCUMCISION IS A MEDICALLY
UNNECESSARY PROCEDURE. AND
WHILE PERFORMING THE ARKHAM
CITY DISCOVER THE CHAO'S TYPE
STATUS SO WE CAN TELL BEFORE.
AND I'M NOT SURE WHAT IT OUT
AND- PUT. DECISION TO PERFORM
THE CONCISION BECAUSE THEY
PERFORM THE PROCEDURE THAT SOME
PEOPLE WOULD. FIGHT AS MEDICAL
NECESSARY. NOW YES. BECAUSE
THAT OUT ALSO HAS TYPE OF SPEED
IS NOW WE DISCOVERED IT DURING
THE IT WAS NOT HAVE TO BE
SEVERELY COVERED DURING THE
PERFORMANCE OF THE
CIRCUMCISION. BUT I THINK THE
BIGGER EASE IS IT IS HIS BEST
BET CONCERNING. NOW ARE
CERTAINLY FALL UNDER MEDICAL
TREATMENT. BUT I WOULD ALSO SAY
THAT YOU KNOW I THINK FIFTY AND
TEN THE BILL AND WHERE WE WANT
TO GO IS IN LINE WITH I THINK
WE'RE THE MEDICAL PROFESSION
WANTS TO GO FOR THE STRAIGHT
TALK TO MAC MANY MY OWN
COLLEAGUES IN THE MEDICAL
PROFESSION- I THINK THE CONCERN
IS THAT THE LAWS A BLUNT
INSTRUMENT. AND TRYING TO PUT
SOMETHING LIKE THIS INTO LAW
AND IT'S NOT LIKE BECAUSE I
KNOW BUT ALSO IS COME UP IS FOR
EXAMPLE CONVERSION THERAPY
THERE IS. PRETTY MUCH IN AN
ENTITY AS MUCH AS THERE CAN BE
IN THE YOU KNOW ABOUT COLON AT
ALL TO FASHION A CONVERSION
THERAPY IS BUNK AND THAT IT I'M
FULL ON THAT SO FORTH. AND IF
YOU THIS SPACE WITHIN WERE
TRYING TO SWEEP OF A LOT
DIFFERENT THINGS THERE'S A LOT
OF. GOOD REASONS FOR THIS THAT
THAT WAS AN INTENT OF THE BILL.
BUT I THINK CONCERNS IT'S ALSO
WE CAN ALLOW OTHERS. THAT
EIGHTY. I THINK SO MUCH OKAY.
THAT JUST MONTH PLEASE I WANT
TO GO TO OTHER SENATORS BUT I
DO WILL DO A FOLLOW UP TO
DOCTOR COP IN IN MAY BE UNFAIR
BUT- TO ASK YOU THIS A GIVEN
YOU HAVE A IF YOU PRACTICE AT
UCSF. BUT A CRITICISM OF THESE
PROCEDURES AT THE SUPPORTERS
SAY THAT THE SURGERIES ARE
OCCURRING AT A MAJOR HOSPITALS
ACROSS THE STATE- CHALLENGING
YOUR ASSERTION INTERNET NOT
WHAT YOU DO AT UCSF BUT CAN YOU
SPEAK TO WHETHER THESE ARE
OCCURRING IN OTHER HOSPITALS.
WELL I THERE ARE. ACROSS YOU
ACROSS CALIFORNIA AND ACROSS
THE UNITED STATES FOR THAT
MATTER THESE- DST MULTI
DISCIPLINARY CLINICS- EXIST ON
A IT ALL OF THE ACADEMIC. THE
MAJORITY THE ACADEMICS AS WITH
IN CALIFORNIA- I THINK THE
PROBLEM WITH. THE END ANSWERING
YOUR QUESTION IS AGAIN WHAT. IT
IS WHICH SURGERIES YOU'RE
TALKING ABOUT BECAUSE THERE ARE
MEDICALLY INDICATED-
INTERVENTIONS FOR- WIN THE
URETHRA AND THE **** ARE ARE
ARE A SINGLE CHANNEL THE EXIT
ON TO THE PERINEUM WHICH IS
THIS OUT OUTER SURFACE OF THE
BODY. AND FOR VARIOUS REASONS
THIS THESE CHANNELS ARE
SEPARATED NOT ONLY TO LIMIT
URINARY TRACT INFECTION BUT YOU
COULD IMAGINE MENSTRUATING
THROUGH A SINGLE HOLE AND
PLACING A TAMPON AND HOW DO YOU
HOW DO YOU URINATE- OF FILLING
AT THAT YOU. POOR DRAINAGE AND-
STATE STENOSIS WHICH IS NEARING
OF THAT CHANNEL CAN- AGAIN
BECAUSE DIFFICULTY WITH
URINATION IN THE URINE GOING UP
INTO THE **** AND UTERUS AND
DILATING THE **** OVERTIME-
THOSE SURGERIES OF MOST LIKELY
PERFORMED AT- IT INSTITUTIONS
ACROSS CALIFORNIA UNITED STATES
WELL LET ME TRY TO NARROW UNDER
YOUR DEFINITION OF INTERSECTS
AND I UNDERSTAND WE HAVE IT. SO
THE IN ON YOU MISSION OKAY AND
I KNOW WE'LL GET TO THAT BUT
UNDER YOUR DEFINITION OF WHAT
INTEREST SEXY IS NOT OTHER
PROCEDURES THAT AS WE TALKING
ABOUT. ARE THOSE ARE. ARE THOSE
PROCEDURES HAPPENING AT AT-
WITHOUT THE SAME
INTERDISCIPLINARY APPROACH THAT
YOU HAVE AT UCSF AND AT OTHER
HOSPITALS FACILITIES AROUND THE
STATE. I DON'T THINK THAT I
COULD. FOR CERTAIN COMMENT ON
WHETHER OR NOT THEY'RE
OCCURRING AT OTHER I THINK THE
MAJORITY RIGHT THEN THE TRADE
DEFINITELY WHEN A CHILD IS BORN
WITH THE INTERSECTS DEFINITION
AS YOU DEFINE IT. IS THAT
SOMETHING THAT IS TYPICALLY A
SURPRISE OR IS IT SOMETHING
THAT IS TYPICALLY A SCENE-
DURING THE PREGNANCY SO THAT
WHEN THAT CHILD IS BORN UNDER
YOUR DEFINITION INTEREST TAX
THAT THE MEDICAL COMMUNITIES
WHERE OF THAT CIRCUMSTANCE. SO
THAT ALSO. WILL GIVE A COMPLEX
ANSWER A CASE SOMETIMES WE WILL
KNOW ABOUT THE DIAGNOSIS BEFORE
THE CHILD IS BORN AND OTHER
TIMES WE WON'T SO FOR EXAMPLE
IN A CHILD WITH. THAT IS
PREVIOUSLY HAD A SIBLING BORN
WAS CH THERE'S A HIGH
LIKELIHOOD THAT THAT AND OTHER
THAN OTHER CHILD WILL BE BORN
WITH CH. THERE OCCASIONALLY
TIMES WHEN WE CAN SEE ON
PRENATAL ULTRASOUND. THE CHILD
LOOKS LIKE IT HAS OF A PHALLIC
LIKE TRUE WOULD BE A- NUMBER TO
**** BUT THERE WAS AN ANALYSIS
SHOWS THAT THEIR EXECS. THERE
OCCASIONALLY TIMES WHEN WERE
ALERTED. AHEAD OF TIME BUT
THERE ARE ALSO TIMES WHEN A
CHILD IS BORN- AND THAT. WE ARE
THAT IT ISN'T IT IS NOT KNOWN
THAT THE CHILD. IS INTERSEX
UNTIL THE CHILD IS BORN NOT ALL
OF MEDICAL CARE IN CALIFORNIA
HAPPENS IN OUR MAJOR URBAN
CITIES WITH MAJOR URBAN
HOSPITALS SO AND RURAL
SETTINGS- AREN'T AREN'T WE
VULNERABLE WITHOUT SOME
PHYSICIAN. WHO ISN'T AS
EDUCATED OR DOESN'T HAVE THE
INTER DISCIPLINARY. AROUND THEM
TO. PERFORM SURGERY. GREAT
THANK. YOU HAVE A- REFERRAL
SYSTEM IN THE TIME WE HEARD
THAT THE CHILDREN THAT WERE
TREATING WITH AN RDSP CLIPPER
NOT COMING OFF FROM SAN
FRANCISCO. SO THOSE CHILDREN
NUMBER IRVINE. AMONG CALL VERY
FREQUENTLY I GET IS FROM STE
THIS. PLACE THROUGHOUT MODESTO.
WHERE OUR CHILDREN HAVE BEEN
BORN IN THERE QUESTION ABOUT
THEIR GENITALIA AND WE HAVE
THEM TRANSFERRED OR A IF
THEY'RE STABLE- THEY CAN THEY
CAN BE DISCHARGED FROM THE
HOSPITAL FOLLOW BERNARD IDEAS
DE CLINIC OKAY AND I WANT TO
CORRECT MYSELF BECAUSE I KNOW
LANGUAGE IS IMPORTANT HERE AND
I USE THE TERM UNNECESSARY
SURGERY AND I SHOULD HAVE SAID-
I SHOULD HAVE SAID- SEX
ASSIGNMENT AT SURGERY WHICH IS
AYE. WHAT I UNDERSTAND THE-
LEAST I ORIGINALLY UNDERSTOOD
AS ESSENCE OF THE BILL SEX
ASSIGNMENT THAT DAY. THAT GOD
LIKE ACT RIGHT OF HURRYING-
WITHOUT AT REAL REASON. OUR OUR
REFLUX IN THESE SITUATIONS IS
NOT TO OPERATE WE DON'T WANT TO
DO SOMETHING THAT IS NOT
IRREPARABLE WE'RE NOT TRYING TO
PERFORM SEX ASSIGNMENT SURGERY
WE DO OUR VERY VERY BEST. TO
ASSESS ALL OF THE INFORMATION
THAT WE CAN GENETICS
ENDOCRINOLOGY SITE IN A
PSYCHIATRY ALL OF THIS AND
MULTIPLE VISITS WITH FAMILIES
AND IF THERE'S ANY QUESTION
WE'RE NOT OPERATING. ALL RIGHT.
MISTER CHAIRMAN IF I WOULD
APPRECIATE IT THOUGHT TO CHIU
BACK COULD HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY
TO. THE THAT'S BEEN A LOT FROM
OF OTHER WOMEN WE'RE GONNA GET
THE WILL HAVE PLENTY OF TIME
THE WAY THAT I WHAT I THINK WE
HAVE ANOTHER UROLOGIST HERE WHO
I THINK HAS A DIFFERENT
PERSPECTIVE AND I WOULD HOPE
THAT. WE DON'T DO CHIU BUCKET
ALSO RESPOND TO THESE QUESTIONS
RATHER THAN JUST HAVING. A ONE
SIDED AT. AT THE CENTER LEYVA
IS ASKING SPECIFICALLY DOCTORS
YOU THAT WOULD YOU LIKE TO.
RESPOND THANK YOU ARE STILL
HELLO EVERYONE- AND YOU KNOW MY
NAME IS BARBARA CHIU BACK. I'M
AN ASSISTANT PROFESSOR OF
UROLOGY AT THE ICAHN SCHOOL OF
MEDICINE AT MOUNT SINAI IN NEW
YORK. ON MY CLINICAL PRACTICE
RESEARCH TEACHING ARE FOCUSED
ON THE DIAGNOSIS AND TREATMENT
OF SEXUAL DYSFUNCTION IN ADULTS
SO JUST TO BE CLEAR I'M NOT A
PEDIATRIC UROLOGIST. BUT I WAS
FIRST EXPOSED TO THE
CONTROVERSY AROUND SURGICAL
MANAGEMENT OF INTERSEX. EARLY
IN MY MEDICAL CAREER WISE
APPLYING TO MEDICAL SCHOOL I'M
AND THIS AWARENESS MOTIVATED
NOT ONLY MY INTERESTING GOING
INTO UROLOGY BUT ALSO MY
DECISION TO DEFER RESIDENCY. TO
FIRST PURSUE A FELLOWSHIP AND
DEGREE IN BIOETHICS SO I BRING
A BOTH THOSE PERSPECTIVES TO
OUR DISCOURSE TODAY. ON A
COUPLE OF THINGS THAT CAME UP.
IN THE COURSE OF THAT THE BACK
AND FORTH ON. SO MANY I TRIED
TO TAKE NOTES SO I WOULD MISS
ANYTHING BUT FORGIVE ME I MIGHT
HAVE TO CIRCLE BACK AS OUR
CONVERSATION CONTINUES. ON YEAH
WITH. IN THE NUMBER OF FUNDING
WHICH HAS TO MONNING TO THE TO
THIS ARE TO THIS BILL- THERE
WAS A CONFLATION OF MEDICAL AND
SURGICAL CARE AND I THINK IT'S
REALLY IMPORTANT THAT WE
RECOGNIZE THAT NO ONE NOTHING
IN THIS BILL IS LIMITING
MEDICAL CARE FOR THESE PATIENTS
DIAGNOSED WITH THE SP ON. THE
TO CONTINUE YOU KNOW WHAT IT'S
TALKING ABOUT LIMITING SURGERY
IS DONE BEFORE SIX YEARS OF AGE
ON. THE HERE QUESTION THAT WAS
RAISED OF IDENTIFYING A HYPE
THE SPEEDIEST AT THE MOMENT OF
CIRCUMCISION ON THAT IS
EXCLUDED FROM THIS BILL WHICH
VERY EXPLICIT LEAD DOES NOT
ADDRESS QUESTIONS OF DESPITE
THE SPEEDIEST ON HERE WITH. THE.
QUESTION OF WHAT IS AND IS NOT
MEDICALLY NEEDED- IT IS OF
COURSE A VERY THORNY ONE ON AND.
IT WAS CERTAINLY THE- THERE IS
ROOM FOR CRITICISM OF THE
BILL'S PROPOSAL THAT'D BE
PUSHED TO A MULTI DISCIPLINARY
TEAM UNDER THE AUSPICES OF THE
MEDICAL BOARD. YOU FOR EXAMPLE
DR **** MENTIONED THE ISSUE OF
THE UROGENITAL SINUS WHERE
THERE IS A COMBINED CHANNEL FOR
THE EXIT OF URINE AND MEN SEIZE
ON THAT ISSUE OF THE MENSTRUAL
FLUID BEING A BEING A
PROBLEMATIC ON DOESN'T ARISE.
BEFORE AGE SIX CHILDREN OR ARE
YOU EVEN WITH THAT IT'S GETTING
EARLIER AND EARLIER- YOU KNOW
THAT IS NOT THE USUAL SITUATION
AND THAT A SIX YEAR OLD IS
GOING TO BE GRAPPLING WITH THAT
PROBLEM. AND SO THERE IS SPACE
TO PAUSE WITHOUT INJURY TO
THESE CHILDREN ON AND FINALLY I
SAID THE TERM INVENTIONS OF
VERY VERY ASTUTELY THAT MULTI
DISCIPLINARY TEAMS ARE
SOMETHING THAT IT WOULD
CERTAINLY OUR OUR PROFESSION
THAT HAS- CALLED FOR NOW. FOR A
VERY LONG TIME BUT THE
UNFORTUNATE REALITY IS THAT
THEY ARE OBSERVE MORE IN THE
BREACH THAN IN THE OBSERVANCE
OF WONDERFUL ACADEMIC CENTERS
LIKE UCSF YES HAVE YOU ROBUST
AND TRULY MULTI DISCIPLINARY
TEAMS BUT THE REALITY IS THAT
EVEN AT MOST ACADEMIC MEDICAL
CENTER IS. A MULTI DISCIPLINARY
TEAM IS A UROLOGIST AN
ENDOCRINOLOGIST AND NOT THE
FULL ARRAY OF PERSONNEL THAT
DOCTOR COP DESCRIBES AT UCSF
AND THAT THE BILL. PRESCRIBED
ACT THE MEDICAL BOARD. VERY
GOOD THANK YOU RELIGION UNDER
TO BACK I WANT INVITE OTHER
SENATORS WHO HAVE QUESTIONS AND
I DO HAVE SOME THAT I'M HOLDING
AND THEN WILL AND BY THE AUTHOR
TO ENGAGE FURTHER. A CENTER
LEYVA. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR-
THANK YOU SENATOR WINNER FOR
YOUR WORK ON THIS BILL. I JUST
DR COP I AGREE AGREE WITH YOU
WHEN YOU SAY THAT IS A COMPLEX
ISSUE AND CHILDREN WILL SUFFER
PROFOUND CONSEQUENCES IF THIS
BILL PASSES I WOULD NOT AGREE
WITH THAT AND SAY THAT I THINK
THAT CHILDREN ARE SUFFERING
PROPELLANT PROFOUND
CONSEQUENCES NOW. I THINK THE
BILL YOU YOU'VE DONE SOME WORK
ON IT I'M GONNA MOVE THE BILL
AT THE APPROPRIATE TIME BUT I'D
LIKE TO SEE WHAT DO SOME MORE
WORK ON IT I THINK IT IS AN
INCREDIBLY COMPLEX ISSUE BUT
IT'S PEOPLE'S LIVES THAT WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT CHILDREN'S LIVES
TO BECOME ADULTS AND IF WE
DON'T GET IT RIGHT THEN THERE
ARE PROFOUND CONSEQUENCES SO- I
HEAR BOTH SIDES YOU'RE BOTH
VERY PASSIONATE I DO WORRY THAT
AT- AT THAT HOSPITAL IS NOT A
TEACHING HOSPITAL. THAT MAYBE
THERE ISN'T THE- JUST THE
ATTENTION GIVEN TO THE ISSUE
THAT IS GIVEN AT- AT A HOSPITAL
LIKE UCSF. AND IF WE EVER HAD
JUST LEADERS CAN'T DO SOMETHING
TO HELP THE PROCESS AND TRY TO
GET IT RIGHT. THE BIG ISSUE WE
DON'T ALWAYS GET IT RIGHT SO
THIS AS US AND WIENER SAID THIS
IS THE FIRST POLICY COMMITTEE.
AND IT HAS A LONG WAY TO GO AND
I ALWAYS LIKE TO THINK THAT IS
BILLS MOVE THROUGH EACH POLICY
COMMITTEE THEY GET A LITTLE
BETTER HOPEFULLY- BUT I'D LIKE
A SISSY TO CONTINUE THIS
BECAUSE I THINK IT'S SUCH A
HUGE HUGE. ISSUE AND AS A NEW
GRANDMOTHER- THERE'S THINGS
THAT YOU LEARN IN THIS JOB THAT
YOU DIDN'T KNOW WHEN YOU HAD
YOUR OWN CHILDREN I DIDN'T KNOW
ANYTHING ABOUT INTERSEX. AND I
REMEMBER YOU KNOW SHE'S THREE
MONTHS OLD THINKING. WOW I
WONDER IF THIS IS SOMETHING
THAT WE WILL HAVE TO DEAL WITH
AND THINKING ABOUT TALKING
ABOUT THE BABY AS A BABY. AND
NOT AS A HE OR A SHE AND HOW
IMPORTANT THAT IS AT AS ONE OF
THE WITNESSES I THINK WAS PRE
TESTIFIED- A BIT YOU KNOW. WE
DON'T FOCUS ON A HEALTHY BABY
SOMETIMES WE TOO MUCH FOCUS ON
IS THAT A BOY IS THAT A GIRL
AND IF THERE'S ANYTHING THAT
DOESN'T LOOK EXACTLY LIKE A BOY
OR GIRL. WE TO FREAK OUT- SO I
THINK OF IT ONE OF THE
BENEFITS- IN JOB AND IN THIS
BILL. IS THAT WE GET OUT THERE
THAT THE PUBLIC IS NOT USED TO
TALKING ABOUT. AND I APPLAUD
THE WITNESSES WHO CAME AND
pSTORIES BECAUSE THAT'S EASY TO
DO BUT IT MAKES US SMARTER.
SAYS LEGISLATOR. SO THANK YOU
WIENER I THANK ALL THE
WITNESSES- I WOULD LIKE TO SEE
A FEW MORE TWEAKS TO THE BILL
AND MAYBE NARROW THE SCOPE. BUT
I WILL- OF THE BILL WHEN
APPROPRIATE MISTER CHAIR. VERY
GOOD. AT CENTER WIENER I THINK
THAT- FIRST THANK YOU FOR YOUR
YOUR PATIENCE AND YOUR-
PASSION- IN AN AREA OF. GREAT
IMPORTANCE AND I KNOW YOU FOR
A- WORK WITH MY STAFF AND WITH
ME AND WITH OTHERS TO TRY TO
FIND. COMPROMISE IF WE CAN FROM
OUR HEARING THAT WE HAD- LAST
YEAR- AND I KNOW A LOT OF WORK
HAS BEEN PUT IN AND I
APPRECIATE IT VERY MUCH. OF I'M
TRYING TO YOU KNOW I THINK THAT
SOME OF THE ISSUES THAT REMAIN
FOR ME- WHAT THAT ONE OF THEM
IS THE ISSUE OF DEFINITION. AND
WE'VE TALKED ABOUT THIS HERE
THIS ONE THIS AFTERNOON A
LITTLE BIT. THAT AYE AYE OPPOSE
AS YOU DO SEX ASSIGNMENT
SURGERY- AND LESS THAT IT IT
THERE IS A COMPLETE EXAMINATION
BY MEDICAL PROFESSIONALS- WHERE
THE SEX OF THE CHILD IS UNCLEAR
SO I THINK THERE'S A PLACE
WHERE WE ARE IN AGREEMENT-
ABOUT SEX SIMON SURGERY WORD
GETS DIFFICULT IS THAT THERE
ARE CIRCUMSTANCES IN WHICH- YOU
KNOW THERE'S I WOULD PUT THAT
THREE THREE CATEGORIES CATEGORY
A IS WHERE A CHILD IS BORN WITH
THAT- MALE CHROMOSOMES AND MALE
ORGANS- CATEGORY B. AS A CHILD
BORN WITH FEMALE CHROMOSOMES IN
FEMALE ORGANS. AND CATEGORY SEE
WHICH FOR ME IS THE INTERSEX
CATEGORY WHERE ALL THAT IS IN
QUESTION- AND AB AND SO WERE
I'M HAVING DIFFICULTIES IS THAT
IF YOU FIT IN CATEGORY A OR B.
WHERE THINGS ARE ALIGNED EXCEPT
FOR SOME PHYSICAL
CHARACTERISTIC OR PHYSICAL
TRAIT- WHY NOW GOES INTO THIS
CATEGORY IT INTERSECTS- AND
THEREFORE WOULD HAVE THE
LIMITATIONS THAT YOU DESCRIBE
IN THE BILL IN TERMS OF WHAT.
COULD OCCUR. COULD YOU COULD
YOU SPEAK TO THAT. SURE MISTER
CHAIRMAN AND THANK YOU FOR THAT
OPPORTUNITY- AND I'M ASSUMING
THAT YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT A
SITUATION WHERE THERE IS NOT. A
MEDICAL NECESSITY WHERE THERE'S
NOT- HEALTH CONDITIONS OF FOR
EXAMPLE WE'VE HEARD ABOUT YES
YES BECAUSE I AND I GUESS ON
BECAUSE IT'S BEEN A LITTLE BIT
OF COMPLETION TODAY. EVERYONE
AGREES THAT IF THIS FITS CA
EIGHTY UNDERLINING ADRENAL. UP
PROBLEM ADRENALYN BALANCE WE
ALL AGREE THAT THAT MUST BE
TREATED IMMEDIATELY IT'S A
MEDICAL EMERGENCY NOTHING IN
THIS BILL STOPS THE TREATMENT
TO CORRECT- OR ADDRESS THE
ADRENAL IMBALANCE NOTHING IN
THIS BILL. STOP SIGN BUT ONCE
YOU ADDRESS MEDICALLY THE
ADRENALINE BALANCE THE QUESTION
IS. DO YOU THAT AND PROCEED TO
PERFORM. THE SURGERY TO QUOTE
UNQUOTE NORMAL LIVES- THE
GENERALS- SO I JUST WANT TO BE
CLEAR ABOUT THAT- SO ON THE- IF
YOU THINK OF HELL LET US STEP
BACK AND THINK ABOUT. A
TRANSGENDER PEOPLE SOMEONE WHO
IS BORN WITH X. Y. CHROMOSOMES.
WHO HAS GENERAL'S ARE. ANY OF
US IF ANYONE WE'RE LOOKING AT A
DOCTOR PARENTS AND WE SAY THAT
IS A 100% WHAT WE WOULD
CONSIDER TO BE A NORMAL LOOKING
QUOTE UNQUOTE **** EVERYTHING
ABOUT THIS BABY SAYS MAIL. ON
BUT THEN. THAT BABY FIVE YEARS
LATER OR TEN YEARS LATER
FIFTEEN YEARS LATER IDENTIFIES
AS A WOMAN AND SO EVEN IN THAT
IN THAT SITUATION YOU DESCRIBE
WHERE THERE IS. A CRIME EXACTA
X. Y. SOMETHING THAT CLEARLY IS
A **** OR **** THAT DOESN'T
MEAN THAT THAT YOU SAID
SUCCESSFULLY ABOUT GENDER THAT
DOESN'T MEAN THAT THAT. CHILD
IS GOING TO END UP. IDENTIFIED
WITH A GENDER AND YET. A GENDER
DECISION HAS BEEN MADE FOR THAT
CHILD. A VISIT BY THE. WITHOUT
ANY IMPORT IT'S NOT ABOUT SEX
IT'S ABOUT GENDER PUTTING ASIDE
EVEN THE A SENSE OF BERMAN HARM
BUT CENTER SEX AND GENDER WITH
ALL RESPECT SEX AND GENDER. I'M
NOT TALKING ABOUT GENDER HOW
YOU I SELF IDENTIFY AND TALKING
ABOUT. YOUR PHYSICAL
CHARACTERISTICS NOW. BECAUSE
YOU CAN- BUT WHATEVER YOUR
PHYSICAL CHARACTERISTICS YOU
CAN IDENTIFY. AT WHATEVER YOU
WANT- IDENTIFIED RIGHT SO YOU
CAN HAVE. ALL MALE PARTS ALL
FEMALE PARTS- YOU CAN DECIDE
YOU'RE THE OPPOSITE IN TERMS OF
YOUR OWN YOUR OWN GENDER
SELECTION SO I'M I WANT TO
SEPARATE THEM HERE BECAUSE I
THINK THAT I DON'T THINK YOU
CAN SEPARATE THE MISTER
CHAIRMAN I DON'T THINK YOU CAN.
THIS IS ABOUT TO SELL SOMEONE
SELF IDENTIFIES THIS IS ABOUT
WHAT SOMEONE IS WITH THEIR
GENDER IS AND GENDER DOES NOT
ALWAYS CONFORM. TO CHROMOSOMES
I AGREE THAT IS OUR GUNS AND
WE'RE IN AGREEMENT THERE SO
THERE'S NO DIFFERENCE. THAT IF
YOU DECIDE THAT- YOU'RE GAY
THAT DOESN'T THAT'S NOT
NECESSARILY ON YOUR BODILY
PARTS BUT HOW DO YOU FEEL ABOUT
YOURSELF. WE AGREE THAT'S A
GENDER SELECTION BUT I'M ONLY
TALKING ABOUT THE PHYSICAL. THE
PHYSICAL- CIRCUMSTANCES IN
WHICH THAT. THAT OUT IS BRN
WITH IT I BUT THE ROOM WHERE
THERE IS NO CONFLICT I'M GONNA
GIVE YOU APPALLING
OPPORTUNITIES DANCER WHERE
THERE IS NO CONFLICT. BETWEEN
CHROMOSOMES AND TRADE EXCEPT
FOR SOME ISSUE- IT AND WE
TALKED ABOUT AT A CH IS ONE
EXAMPLE OF THAT- THAT THAT IS
THAT I'M I'M TRYING TO
UNDERSTAND THAT THAT IS NOT-
AYE AYE ISSUE OF YOUR OWN SELF
IDENTITY. ANY POINT IN YOUR
LIFE THROUGH ABOUT WHAT BUT IF
YOU. WITHIN A- LITERATE. AND
THAT. TOO WOULD TO QUOTE
UNQUOTE NORMAL SIZE. ON THAT
WHERE IN THAT IS IT CONDUCT
CREATING A CONFORMANCE WHERE IS
THAT IS A CREATING AYE AYE SEX
ASSIGNMENT THAT'S WHAT I'M
TRYING TO GET TO. SO LET'S SAY
YOU HAVE A BABY THAT'S BORN
WITH ACCEPTS CHROMOSOMES. WITH
TWO. A BABY THAT'S BORN WITH
AFFECTS TONES AND A LARGE AND A
LARGE **** INCIDENTS SURGERY IS
PERFORMED AND SIMILAR IS NOT A
MEDICAL CONDITION LET'S SAY IT
COULD BE FROM CH AND A THREE ON
BALANCE THE DRESS AND THEN A
CLITORAL REDUCTION IS
PERFORMANCE I MEAN YOU'RE
REMOVING TISSUE- AND THEN LET'S
SAY FIVE YEARS DOWN THE LINE OR
TENER FOR THE- BACK. KID SAYS
BUT I'M A BOY. YOU AND THAT.
THE SIDES I WANT TO HAVE
SURGERY TO COME FOR MY BODY TO
A MY GENDER IS. BY THAT SURGERY
PERFORMED AS A CHILD AS A BABY
COULD MAKE IT HARDER OR EVEN
PRECLUDE THE SURGICAL
INTERVENTIONS INVOLUNTARY ONCE
A WEEK SO BY TWO BY MAKING THAT
CHOICE THE SAID WE THINK THIS
IS WHAT YOU ARE YOU HAVEN'T
TOLD US THAT. YOU CAN'T TALK
YOUR BABY. THEN YOU PERFORM THE
SURGERY THAT MAKES IT HARDER
FOR THAT PERSON TO DO WHAT THEY
WANT TO DO WITH THEIR BODY
BASED ON THEIR GENDER IN THE
FUTURE DOT THAT'S WHY THESE
PERMANENT DECISIONS CAN BE SO
CATASTROPHIC FOR PEOPLE CAUGHT
IT AND I THINK THAT'S A GOOD
EXPLANATION AND ONE THAT I
AGREE WITH IN TERMS OF WHAT.
THAT THAT- CONCLUSION COULD BE
BUT THE OTHER SIDE OF IT IS
THAT ALL THOSE. CHILDREN WHO
HAVE HAD THAT PROCEDURE DONE
WHO WHO HAD THAT- HAD THE
TISSUE CHANGED IN SOME FASHION.
AND THEY'RE HAPPY WITH THAT
MMHM CIRCUMSTANCE RIGHT AND SO
WHILE I AGREE WITH YOU THAT.
YOU COULD HAVE AND IN CERTAIN
CASES WHERE. YOU'RE UNHAPPY
WITH THAT PROCEDURE BEING DONE.
HOW DO WE TAKE INTO ACCOUNT ALL
THOSE OTHERS WHERE THAT
PROCEDURE ACTUALLY. ENHANCE
THEIR LIFE PHYSICALLY MENTALLY
AND LOTS OF WAYS RIGHT WHICH IS
ALSO A POSITIVE. AND WE DO
THAT. BY SAYING THAT WHEN
YOU'RE SIX YEARS OLD. YOU CAN
HAVE THE SURGERY AND IF YOU
LOOK AT AND WHAT WE DO IN THIS
LEGISLATURE. EVERY DAY. AND
IT'S REALLY HARD FOR ALL OF US.
IS THERE THERE ARE SOME PIECES
THAT THERE'S SOME ISSUES THAT
ARE SO CLEAR CUT. THERE ARE
OTHER ISSUES WHERE THERE ARE
YOU NOT IT'S NOT. AS YOU KNOW
THERE THERE ARE BALANCING
EQUITIES. AND THE QUESTION IS
AYE AYE WE AGREED THERE ARE
PEOPLE WHO HAVE THE SURGERY.
TWO YEARS LATER ARE. REALLY
HAPPY THAT THEY HAD THE SURGERY
WE'RE NOT DISPUTING THAT. WE'RE
NOT TRYING TO ERASE THEM. THERE
ARE SOME EFFORTS TO ERASE
INTERSEX PEOPLE. AND MINIMIZE
THEM BUT WE'RE NOT TRYING TO A
RACE OF PEOPLE WHO WERE
SATISFIED WITH THE SURGERY. BUT
THE QUESTION IS IF YOU HAVE
SOMEONE WHO. HOW NEAT ONCE THE
SURGERY AND CAN. THE LADY AT
THE SIX DOESN'T PREVENT THEM
FROM HAVING IT. AND THEN THEY
GO ON THEIR PUT THEIR LIVES.
FIRST IS THE PERSON WHO. HAS
THE SURGERY IS A BABY. AND THEN
WITH THE ROLE AND ARE NOT
SATISFIED WITH THE AND IT'S TOO
LATE THEY CAN'T DO ANYTHING
ABOUT IT. WE'RE THE EQUITIES
LIE. THE THERE'S ONLY ONE GROUP
THERE. WHO ARE WHO IF YOU CAN
NOT MAKE THAT CHANGE IN THE
FUTURE BECAUSE THE DECISIONS
MADE FOR THEM. SO IN THE
EQUITIES OR PRETTY CLEAR HERE
ON THAT PARTICULAR ISSUE. OKAY
I APPRECIATE YEAR.
CLARIFICATION AT SOME PLACE WE
MAY HAVE SOME DIFFERENCES ON. I
SPOKE EARLIER ABOUT SOMEONE
BEING GAY AT THAT SEXUAL
ORIENTATION I DIDN'T MAKE
IMMEDIATE AND IMPLIES THAT NOT
IT YES I GENDER I TO MISTER
CHAIRMAN GIVEN VERY SUPPORTIVE
OF OUR COMMUNITY AND I
APPRECIATE THAT. ALL RIGHT-
THIS IS THE SECOND THAT. THE
SECOND PLACE THAT THE THIRD
PLACE TODAY MAYBE YOU COULD
SPEAK TO IS THAT. IN YOUR BILL
IT PUTS LIMITATIONS ON WHAT.
PROCEDURES CAN CAN- GO FORWARD-
AND BUT YOU DEFEND YOU CREATIVE
COMMITTEE IN THE MEDICAL BOARD
TO DO THAT GOT TO PROVIDE THAT
GUIDANCE BUT- BUT YOUR BILL
SAYS THAT THE PROCEDURE CANNOT
CARRY ANY. MEANINGFUL RISK OF
HARM. THAT'S A VERY BROAD
DEFINITION. OF WHERE THINGS CAN
BE DONE I MEAN IT'S ALMOST
NOTHING YOU CAN DO IN THAT AND
WE CAN INVITE OUR MEDICAL
PROFESSIONALS HERE TO. ADVISE
ON THIS BUT THERE'S ALMOST
NOTHING THAT ONE CAN DO.
MEDICALLY THAT DOESN'T CREATE
SOME. POTENTIAL FOR HARM COULD
YOU SPEAK TO THAT YEAH SURE A
AND I THINK THE REASON FOR THAT
IN SHORT IS THAT WE ARE. NOT
GIVING THE MEDICAL BOARD THIS
IS ALREADY TO CRAFT. THE
STANDARDS. BUT WE ARE ALSO
GUIDING IT BY SAYING THAT WE
DON'T. IT THAT IF SOMETHING IN
TERMS OF WHAT'S MEDICALLY
NECESSARY BECAUSE WE ARE ERRING
ON THE SIDE OF BEING.
RESTRICTIVE WHEN THERE IS NOT.
AN IMMEDIATE MEDICAL ISSUE- AND
ON THE IT THE ON THE ISSUE OF.
A MEDICAL NECESSITY SO WE HAVE
YOU EVER GONE THROUGH IN THIS
BILL WE PUT THE MEDICAL BOARD
AND- AS A WAY OF SAYING OKAY
WE'RE NOT GOING TO MICROMANAGE
THIS THIS IS THE BOARD THAT
OVERSEES THE MEDICAL PROFESSION
CLEAR ON THE DEFINITION OF
MEDICAL NECESSITY ITEM CRYSTAL
CLEAR IN MEETINGS WITH THE
OPPOSITION OTHERWISE. THAT WE
ARE. ABSOLUTELY OPEN TO NEW.
IDEAS ABOUT WHAT IF THE IF THIS
ISN'T THE RIGHT APPROACH OF THE
RIGHT DEFINITION. TO THE FINING
MIDDLETON SAYS HE WE INVITE.
IDEAS AND LANGUAGE- I'VE HAD
MEETINGS WITH THE CALIFORNIA
MEDICAL ASSOCIATION WHERE
THEY'VE RAISED THEY DON'T LIKE
OUR APPROACH TO THE FINING
MEDICAL NECESSITY AND I SAID
GREAT. CAN YOU PLEASE PROVIDE
ME WITH YOUR IDEA THEY HAVEN'T
DONE THAT AND THAT'S NOT A
CRITICISM. BECAUSE THEY TAKEN-
BASICALLY CATEGORICAL
OPPOSITION SO THEY'RE NOT YOU
KNOW. ENGAGING WITH US ON THE
DETAILS OF THE BILL IN
PROPOSING TO BUYING FOR THEIR
SIMPLY OPPOSE I'M NOT
CRITICIZING THEM. BUT IT MAKES
IT CHALLENGING MISTER CHAIRMAN
WHEN. YOU HAVE THESE ISSUES AND
YOU HAVE OPPOSITION WHO WERE
WERE NOT ENGAGE ON THAT LEVEL
THAT DOES MAKE IT MORE- MORE
CHALLENGING SO WE AND WE ARE
ALSO AWAITING. MEDICAL WHERE WE
HAVEN'T RECEIVED IT YET BUT WE
WILL- ABOUT THEIR TAKE ON THIS
AND WHETHER THEY WOULD LIKE
CHANGES SO- YOU KNOW CENTER
LEYVA IS ABSOLUTELY RIGHT THIS
BILL. ON WILL CONTINUE THIS IS
NOT ONE WHERE WE'RE SAYING
WE'RE NEVER GOING TO MAKE ANY
AMENDMENTS IS BUT WE HAVE MADE
AMENDMENTS BASED ON FEEDBACK.
THE CRIME EVEN THOUGH WE DON'T
HAVE OPPOSITION WHO WORKS WITH
US. ON THOSE AMENDMENTS AND
WILL CONTINUE- WILL CONTINUE TO
DO THAT- AND I GUESS I CAN I
CAN SAYS NOW OUR MICHAEL OR OR
MY CLOTHES BECAUSE I THERE WERE
SOME STATEMENTS MADE. BY THE
OPPOSITION THANK ARE JUST
FACTUALLY. INACCURATE SO MISTER
CHAIRMAN I DON'T KNOW IF YOU
WANT ME TO WAIT TO TALK ABOUT
THAT OR DO IT NOW. YEAH YOU'RE
WELCOME TO DO IT AS YOUR
CLOTHES YEAH OKAY I THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN SO COLLEAGUES
AGAIN THANK YOU FOR HEARING THE
SAID I KNOW THIS IS BEEN A LONG
HEARING THIS IS BEEN A
CONTROVERSIAL BILL BUT IT'S- AN
IMPORTANT ONE AND IT DOES
IMPLICATE THE BASIC CIVIL.
RIGHTS AND- HUMAN RIGHTS OF
THESE- INTERSECTS INDIVIDUALS
OF INTERSEX COMMUNITY DOES
EXIST AND YOU'VE HEARD
STATEMENTS TODAY ABOUT THAT FEW
IT'S RARE. EXACTLY HIGHER
PERCENTAGE. THAT THE MOTHER
COMMITTEES. IT IS NOT AN
INSIGNIFICANT NUMBER. OF. YOU
YOU KNOW WHEN YOU- WE HEARD
ABOUT- NINE AS STATISTIC 95% OF
CH- PATIENCE AND UP IDENTIFYING
IS FEMALE. BRISTOL THAT MEANS
ONE IN TWENTY DON'T. AND THEY
JUST GOT THAT SURGERY EVEN
THOUGH IT DOESN'T CONFORM-
THEY'RE ACTUALLY THERE IS DATA
INDICATING- THAT ABOUT ONE IN
EIGHT DON'T IDENTIFIES FEMALE
SO MORE THAN DOUBLE. THE
STATISTICS THAT YOU HEARD
TODAY. FOR PROXIMAL HYPOSPADIAS
WHICH IS STILL PART OF THE
BILL. TWENTY FIVE PERCENT. OF
THOSE PATIENTS. DO NOT IDENTIFY
AS MALE. AND YET THE SURGERIES.
QUOTE UNQUOTE FIX THEIR ****
EVEN THOUGH THEY END UP ONE IN
FOUR IDENTIFY AS FEMALE. ON WE
ALSO HER YOU KNOW I'M I
REPRESENT A DISTRICT INCLUDES
UCSF- I AM- I SAID THIS BEFORE
SAID AGAIN I AM INTENSELY
PROUD. OF THE UCS OFFICE OF THE
DISTRICT I REPRESENTS ONE OF
THE VERY VERY I'LL SAY IT IT IT
IT'S THE BEST INSTITUTION THE
WORLD WHAT'S THE THREE IT'S AND
I'M AND I LOVE SORRY OKAY. I
SAID I SHOULDN'T OFFEND MY
COLLEAGUES ON THE RUN IN MY
BILL BUT I. I'M VERY PROUD TO
REPRESENT YOU SEE US OUT AND I-
AND ONE OF THE REASONS I CHOSE
INSURANCE THAT I CHOSE BECAUSE
I CAN GO TO USE YES UP IF I
NEED TO- SO I LOVE UCSF BUT-
AT. BUT I THINK WE ALSO NEED TO
BE CLEAR THAT THE SURGERIES ARE
BEING PERFORMED. ON AND WE KNOW
THAT EVEN FROM YOU SEE THIS
STUFF- THERE WAS IF ANYONE I
DON'T KNOW IF ANYONE SERVING
MIDEAST HEARD THE RESOLUTION
AND TWENTY EIGHTEEN. THERE WAS
A POSITION THAT YOU CASF DOCTOR
BASKIN WHO CAME UP REPEATEDLY
AND IT WAS CRYSTAL CLEAR THE
SURGERIES WERE BEING PERFORMED
HE STOPPED COMING OUT OF
BECAUSE HE WAS SAYING SOME
REALLY. OVER THE TOP THINGS ARE
NOT HIS FROM UCSF. AND WE KNOW
THAT MEDI CAL AND THIS IS THIS
IS A LITTLE BIT OVER BROAD IN
TERMS THE CATEGORY. BUT FIFTEEN
SINCE 200-041-5000 SURGERIES
HAVE BEEN PERFORMED. SOME OF
THOSE HAVE BEEN MEDICALLY
NECESSARY AND SOME OF THOSE ARE
DISTAL HYPE STATUS WOULD BE
TAKEN OUT OF THE BILL. BUT AS
OF THE LOWER NUMBER THE FIFTEEN
THOUSAND. IT'S NOT ZERO AND
IT'S NOT EVEN CLOSE TO ZERO YES
IT WAS WORSE THIRTY YEARS AGO I
ABSOLUTELY AGREE THE MEDICAL
PROFESSION. IS A BALDING ON
THIS AND I COMMEND THE MEDICAL
PROFESSION REVOLVING ON THIS.
BUT THAT EVOLUTION IS NOT
COMPLETE THE SURGERIES ARE
STILL HAPPENING WHEN THEY'RE
NOT. MEDICALLY UNNECESSARY I
ALSO- AGREE- WITH THE DOCTOR
THAT THE PHYSICIANS WILL NOT
WILLFULLY HARM ANYONE I THINK-
I. MEAN THAT IS THE OPPOSITE OF
PHYSICIANS WANT TO DO RIGHT BY
THEIR PATIENTS. HI THIS IS NOT
ABOUT WILL FULLY HARMING- BUT
THIS IS ABOUT HARM. DOES HAPPEN
AS A RESULT OF THESE CHOICES
EVEN THOUGH IT'S COMPLETELY
NOT. WHAT'S INTENDED FOR TRYING
TO HELP BUT SOMETIMES THAT
HELPS. CAUSES HARM AND THAT'S
WHY WE NEED TO LEGISLATE- WE
ALSO KNOW THAT STATISTICS WE
HAVE IS THAT 90% OF TIPS. WITH
CH ARE RECEIVING VAGINOPLASTY
SIR CLITORAL CLASSES. SO THAT
DOES NOT LIKE IT THAT YOU KNOW
TO SAID THIS IS THIS IS JUST
NOT HAPPENING IT'S NOT REAL IF
IT WEREN'T HAPPENING THE
QUESTION IS. WE WOULDN'T BE
HERE. OR WITH A WHITE AND SAID
LET'S JUST PUT IT INTO LAW. BUT
THE SURGERIES ARE HAPPENING A
AND THAT'S WHY- THIS IS ON.
SORRY THE SO COLLEAGUES- I
APPRECIATE YOUR TAKING TIME TO
BE WITH ME. TO MEET WITH THE
ADVOCATES TO REALLY DO AGAIN.
DEEPLY APPRECIATIVE FOR YOUR
TIME AND YOUR FOCUS AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU I SENATOR
WINNER- YOUR PASSION FOR THIS
ISSUE MAY EVEN EXCEED YOUR
PASSION FOR SB FIFTY. EVEN AT
THE NATION'S ADVOCATE MORE THAN
IT ADVOCATE- YOU CARE GREATLY
ABOUT THIS COMMUNITY- THAT YOU
ARE HOPEFUL THAT THIS BILL WILL
HELP. AND ARE DESERVING OF
GREAT GREAT PRAISE FOR THAT-
AND I THINK THAT- IT'S CLEAR TO
ME THAT WE HAVE A LOTS OF AREAS
OF AGREEMENT- I DON'T SUPPORT
SEX ASSIGNMENT- SURGERY- BUT I
ALSO HAVE TO BE. COGNIZANT OF
THE FACT THAT- THERE ARE A
NUMBER OF THOUGHT THAT THAT
THAT CHILDREN. WHO HAVE HAD
PROCEDURES DONE THAT AREN'T
ABOUT SEX ASSIGNMENT- THAT
PARENTS AND PHYSICIANS IN THEIR
BEST JUDGEMENT AT THOUGHT WERE
TO THEIR BENEFIT. AND I DON'T
THINK THAT NECESSARILY
ESTABLISHES- THEIR GENDER
IDENTITY I THINK IN SOME CASES.
IT COULD POTENTIALLY AFFECT
THAT CIRCUMSTANCE AND THAT'S
NOT A GOOD THING- BUT I THINK
THAT I MIGHT MY CONCERN WITH
WITH YOUR BILL TODAY IS THAT I
THINK IT GOES IN AND THE RIGHT
DIRECTION AND SO MANY DIFFERENT
WAYS AND I AND I. AND IT'S
DIFFICULT TO SAY WELL THEN
LET'S LET'S MOVE FORWARD AND-
BUT I DO THINK IT REQUIRES SOME
MORE WORK AND I DO THINK IT
REQUIRES SOME NARROWING- IN
REGARD TO THE DEFINITION- I
THINK WE CAN FIND A PATHWAY.
UNFORTUNATELY THE BILL IN ITS
CURRENT FORM IS NOT ONE I THINK
THAT WE CAN. STOP SIX
ASSIGNMENT SURGERY IN
CALIFORNIA I THINK WE CAN LEAD
THE NATION ON THIS IMPORTANT
HUMAN RIGHTS ISSUE AND- IT'S
WITH RELUCTANCE THAT I CAN'T
FIND MYSELF UNDER THE BILL AS
WRITTEN TODAY. URGING ITS
PASSAGE. AS SO WITH THAT CENTER
MAY MATTER OF A COUPLE
COMMENTS. THANK YOU AND I HAVE
TO TELL YOU SENATOR WINNER HOW
WOULD IT WHAT A PLESURE IT IS
TO WORK WITH YOU OF IT REALLY
IS BECAUSE YOU YOU ASKED US.
CONTINUOUSLY IN THIS BODY AND
IT IS- YOU KNOW WE SPENT A LOT
OF TIME ON THIS ISSUE WE'VE
TALKED ABOUT IT A NUMBER OF
TIMES AND- YOU KNOW I THINK OF
THE PAIN THAT. THAT THE SIX
ASSIGNMENT. SURGERY HAS CAUSED
IN CERTAIN INSTANCES TO CERTAIN
PEOPLE IN THE DIFFICULTY THAT
THEY HAVE AND- YOU KNOW ANYONE
WHO IS A PARENT OR NOW OF A
GRANDPARENT. YOU KNOW I LOOK AT
THAT THOSE ISSUES AND  JUST
THINK THAT IT IT IS- SUCH A
CHALLENGING CIRCUMSTANCE BUT I
WAS. IS THIS IS EVOLVED IN MY
THINKING THE ISSUE OF. REALLY
DO NO HARM AND I KNOW THE
MEDICAL PROFESSION THAT IS THE
FOUNDATION OF FOR ME I IS I
LOOKED AT THIS YOU KNOW I WAS.
LOOKING AT MY A. MY SENSE OF
THAT IN MY A FEELING OF I DON'T
WANT TO DO HARM. BY MAKING A
DECISION AND I LOOKED AT THE
MEDICAL BOARD IN IN THEIR- ROLE
IN THIS. IN THE COMMITTEE THAT
WOULD BE ESTABLISHED AND I JUST
FIND. I'M NOT COMFORTABLE WITH
THAT AND IN THE SIX YEAR OLD
THAT ARBITRARY NUMBER AGE. I
LOOK AT MY GRANDDAUGHTERS FIVE
ALMOST SIX AND I'M THINKING. I
DON'T KNOW IF THAT'S SOMETHING
THAT. SHE COULD MAKE THAT
DECISION- ON INTO THE A NUMBER
OF. INVOLVED IN THIS IS THE
CHAIR INDICATED I'M THERE. I
JUST. THERE IS JUST TOO MANY
UNCERTAIN FOR ME WERE I THINK
MY VOTE. COULD CAUSE HARM AT
SOME POINT IN TIME AND THAT'S
THE CHALLENGE FOR ME BUT I HOPE
YOU. IF THAT IN SOMETHING
DIFFERENT BILL. I'LL BE VOTING
NO UNFORTUNATELY THANK YOU. ALL
RIGHT A SENATOR GALGIANI- I AM
PROUD TO BE SUPPORTING YOUR
BILL TODAY I'M SOMEONE I HAVE
MULTIPLES- SCOLIOSIS THAT MEANS
THAT MY HAVE OCCURRED MY SPINE
BECAUSE MY LEFT LEG IS A LITTLE
BIT LONGER THAN MY RIGHT LEG I
DIDN'T EVEN KNOW ABOUT IT UNTIL
I WAS MUCH OLDER AND CAME
ACROSS IT WHEN I WAS DOING AT
PHYSICAL FOR TO GET ON THE
TRACK TEAM IN HIGH SCHOOL. I
DON'T KNOW THE MY PARENTS EVEN
KNOW THAT I HAVE IT IT DOESN'T
AFFECT MY DAILY LIFE I FORGET
THAT I EVEN HAVE IT UNTIL
SOMETHING LIKE THIS COMES UP
AND IT MAKES ME THINK ABOUT IT
AND I THINK- WITH ALL OF THEM
PEOPLE WHO. HAVE HAD SURGERIES
WHAT IT MEDICALLY NECESSARY AN
INMATE IN THE FUTURE PRETTY
EARLY FROM RURAL AREAS ARE
AREAS WHERE WE DON'T HAVE
SPECIALISTS THAT ARE AS
ADVANCED IN THEIR KNOWLEDGE
WHICH AND LOCAL I RECALL
KNOWLEDGE IN THE FIELD WHERE
WOULD BE TAKE WOULD BE A. N.
DOT LIFE ALTERING CHANGES AND I
JUST THINK IT'S TIME TO. TO
STOP AND LOOK AT MAYBE THE HARM
THAT'S BEEN DONE AND HOW DO WE
HOW WE PUT A PAUSE ON THAT AND
I TRUST THE MEDICAL FIELD
ENOUGH THAT I BELIEVE IF THERE
WAS AN AGENCY THAT DIDN'T FIT
WITHIN. THE CONFINES THIS BILL
THAT. WOULD BE IN A BILL STILL.
THIS AT THAT THAT. MY PEOPLE
WITH THE INTENTIONS AT HEART
SEE THAT THERE IS A NEED AND
THAT SURGERY COULD OCCUR
WITHOUT HAVING TO COME UNDER
THE ANY PENALTIES UNDER THIS-BILL I DON'T THINK THAT THIS
BILL IS INTENDED TO GO AFTER
DOCTORS AND PENALIZE BUT IT WAS
INTENDED TO SET THE RECORD
STRAIGHT AND JUST TAKE THINGS
BACK AND SAY LET'S NOT LOOK AT
LET'S NOT MUCH EMPHASIS ON
WHAT'S NORMAL AND WHAT SOCIETY
THIS IS NORMALLY LIKE NO ONE
CAN SEE THAT I HAVE A CURVATURE
IN MY SPINE. IT DOESN'T MATTER
TO ME OR TO ANYBODY ELSE AND IF
IT'S SOMETHING THAT SOMEONE
CAN'T SEE UNLESS IT. KLAY
NECESSARY IT SHOULDN'TMATTER
AND I THINK I PUT TOO MUCH
EMPHASIS AS A SOCIETY ON WHAT
IS NORMAL SO. I AM I AM PROUD
TO SUPPORT THE BILL I THINK
THAT THERE IS A PATHWAY TO GET
THERE AND THAT. THE I KNOW THE
AUTHOR I KNOW HS COMMITMENT TO
THE ISSUE I KNOW HIS COMMITMENT
TO WORKING WITH DIFFERENT
GROUPS AND INDIVIDUALS AND
REALLY PERSEVERING TO GET
THINGS RIGHT. I THINK THAT WE
HAVE TIME TO STILL DO THAT
THERE'S ALWAYS FOLLOW UP
LEGISLATION AS WELL BUT- I AM
PROUD TO SUPPORT YOUR BILL
TODAY. THANK YOU SENATOR
GALGIANI SENATOR DOT. I YES-
I'D FOR THE TIME I LIKE
DISSOCIATE MY COMMENTS WAS
SENATOR HILL. BUT JUST ON A
ENFORCEABLE I'D I DO THANK- THE
SENATOR CENTER WIENER FOR- HIS
PASSION ON THIS ISSUE THIS GOES
WAY BACK YOU WITHOUT A NUMBER
OF DIFFERENT. YOUR
CONVERSATIONS AS A GRANDFATHER
TO FOR- ONE BOY IN AND THREE
GRANDDAUGHTERS IN THAT SPACE
BETWEEN FIVE AND SEVEN I COULD
TOTALLY CONCUR I I'D FIND IT
JUST ABSOLUTELY IMPOSSIBLE. TO
BELIEVE AT THAT AGE THAT
THEY'RE GOING TO- I DID THAT
AGES ANY PANACEA FROM THE
STANDPOINT OF TAKING SOMETHING
SO IMPORTANT LIKE THIS AND
MOVING IT YOUR TO AGE SIX I
JUST I JUST. CAN'T SEE IT- YOU
KNOW MAYBE AS TIME MOVES ON IT
ALL LEARN MORE AND- YOU KNOW
CHANGE ON THIS BUT FOR TODAY
I'M JUST NOT GOING TO BE ABLE
TO BE THERE HI THANK YOU
SENATOR DODD. AT CENTER WIENER
DO WE WANT TO LEAVE HERE THIS
IS AND SO DO YOU WHAT DO YOU
WANT TO HAVE A WHAT WHAT WOULD
YOU OUT FURTHER. I WOULD LIKE
TO HAVE A AND I A. EVEN THOUGH
WE'VE ALREADY HAD BACKING A PRE
VOTE OF SORTS- BUT I WOULD AYE
AYE CLOSED I DON'T REALIZE THAT
MEMBERS WERE MAKING COMMENTS
ARCHES TWO QUICK THINGS I WOULD
LIKE TO. ADDRESS I DIDN'T I
THOUGHT IT WAS OVER AND I WOULD
NORMALLY CLOSE AT THE END DOT
BEFORE ALL THE COMMENTS WERE
MADE. BY I JUST TWO QUICK
THINGS- BUT FIRST OF ALL. JUST
TO JUST TO BE CLEAR IN TERMS OF
THE SIX YEAR OLD. THIS BILL
DOESN'T SAID THE SIX YEAR OLD
BESIDES. THIS BILL SAYS A
PARENT DECIDES IN CONSULTATION
WITH THE POSITION. WHEN THE KID
IS SIX WHEN THE AND YES AND WE
DO WE DO THAT WE'RE NOT SEND A
KID MAKES A CHOICE A PARENT
MAKES A CHOICE. AT SIX WHEN THE
KICK IN AT LEAST. SPEAK AND
SPEAK WORDS AND COMMUNICATE AND
SUCH A BIRD THAT I JUST WANT TO
MAKE CLEAR BECAUSE I SOUNDED
LIKE THE THAT- MONITOR THE
CONFUSION THERE. AND TERMS OF
MEDICAL NECESSITY WE MADE A
GOOD FAITH EFFORT TO TRY TO
COME UP WITH A SYSTEM TO
ADDRESS CONCERNS THAT WE HEARD.
BUT IT TOOK TO SAYS WHAT I SAID
THE BEGINNING THIS IS THE FIRST
POLICY COMMITTEE IN THE FIRST
HOUSE OF THE LEGISLATURE- AND
THAT IS AN ISSUE THAT WE'RE
GOING TO CONTINUE TO WORK ON-
I'VE AYE. WE WILL CONTINUE TO
INVITE- CALIFORNIA MEDICAL
ASSOCIATION OTHERS. TO ENGAGE
WITH US ON THE DEFINITION OF
MEDICAL NECESSITY- AND SO I
WOULD HOPE I THINK. I DON'T
THINK ANY OF US IS AS CONSIDER
WE'VE HAD NO BILLS WHETHER OR
MAYBE SOME DEFINITIONS THAT
NEED TO BE WORKED OUT AFTER THE
FIRST POLICY- COMMITTEE- AND SO
I. RESPECTFULLY ASK WHEN I
WROTE. ALL RIGHT VERY GOOD. SO
THIS POINT ON THE RECOGNIZE THE
MOTION FROM SENATOR LEYVA TO
MOVE THE BILL SECRETARY CALL
THE ROLL. MISSION IS TO PASS
THE SENATE JUDICIARY COMMITTEE
GLAZER. CHIANG ARCHULETA. DODD
NO DODD NO. GALGIANI GALGIANI
AYE HILL THE HILL NO LEYVA AYE
LEYVA AYE PAN. AND NOW WILK THE
WELL NOW. ARTS CENTER THE BILL
IS A SHORT OF VOTES TO GET OUT
SORRY ABOUT THAT HOPE THAT WE
CAN WORK TOGETHER EFFUSION
FEDERATION OKAY WITHOUT
OBJECTION THAT THE MATTERS-
WILL BE RECONSIDERED. THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU
CALIFORNIA'S
. THAT BUSINESS AND
PROFESSIONS OFFICIALLY
ADJOURNED